bonsoir
je vais commencer par une annonce parce
que je j'ai j'ai peur de l'oublier parce
qu'elle était pas
prévu parce qu'on vient de faire les
comptes et on va certainement dégager un
petit bénéfice alors on fait on fait
vraiment pas ça pour de
l'argent et et et donc si vous le voulez
bien vous vous nous le direz avec vos
applaudissements on versera ce bénéfice
au resto du cœur
bon ça veut dire que la réponse est
oui
bon vraiment un grand merci d'être venu
aussi nombreux et je dois dire que là la
formule n'est pas galevodée donc c'est
assez impressionnant de vous voir tous
euh donc grand grand merci à vous
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
euh on voulait aussi
remercier le Grand Théâtre de
Provence qui a eu une oreille
extrêmement attentive quand Vigi pirate
ne nous a plus permis de rentrer à la
fac des sciences où on avait un amphi de
800 places et donc aujourd'hui on se
retrouve 1300 dans cette belle salle du
GTP
on veut vraiment remercier toutes les
équipes du Grand Théâtre de Provence qui
ont été vraiment à notre disposition à
notre écoute et extrêmement bienveillant
c'est un vrai plaisir d'être d'être ici
et d'organiser cette
rencontre
alors un grand merci aux différentes
associations qui ont organisé cette
rencontre il s'agit de pachchamama les
Amis du Monde diplomatique les
d'conomistes qui assurent toute la vidéo
et la vidéo sera disponible en fin de
semaine prochaine le temps qu'on fasse
les montages sur la chaîne youtube Des
déconomistes d'conomistes avec deux
zenes puisque ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'économie mais avec
déconné
ce sera également aussi disponible sur
la chaîne des shifters et sur la chaîne
de réseau salariat euh donc les
shifteurs fait font partie de
l'association qui organise cette
rencontre et réseau salariat
également on voulait remercier tout
spécialement également les bénévoles
leur enthousiasme et leur et leur
énergie Corresp contribu au succès de
cette rencontre je pense qu'on peut les
[Applaudissements]
applaudir et bien sûr un grand grand
grand merci à Bernard Friot et à
Jean-Marc janovissi qui ont
répondu alors comment va se dérouler
cette r contre euh d'abord les échanges
de nos deux conférenciers dureront 1h10
ensuite vous aurez la parole jusqu'à
21h15 donc chacun d'entre vous disposera
de 2 minutes pour intervenir ou poser
une question au-delà des 2 minutes vous
verrez il y a une petite musique qui se
mettra en route pour vous dire que vous
avez utilisé votre temps de parole voilà
et si si vous prolongez au-delà des 2
minutes ah non je vais pas le dire parce
que il y en en a qui vont relever de
défi donc voilà je m'arrête
là
euh à 21h15 il faudra absolument que
nous quittions la la salle de spectacle
donc il faudra sortir à 21h15 c'est le
contrat qu'on a passé avec le Grand
Théâtre de de Provence mais on on se
retrouvera de toute façon dans le hall
du du théâtre et là on pourra prolonger
les échanges
et mais ce il faudra le à son tour le
quitter à
21h45 mais on pourra aussi continuer les
échanges dehors dans le
PAO on a tout
prévu donc comme je vous le disiez on
est vraiment très très heureux de
recevoir et d'accueillir jean-marcoviss
et Bernard Friot Bernard Friot est
économiste il est également sociologue
et il est le théoricien du salaire à vie
Jean-Marc jancovicii est le président du
shift projject qui est le sing Tang de
la transition bac carbone donc pour
lancer le débat j'ai une première
question qui est la suivante la
nécessaire réduction des machines
impliquet-elle la décroissance et c'est
Bernard qui s'y colle en premier
je propose quant à moi de refuser les
termes abstraits du débat croissance
versus
décroissance la croissance dans nos
sociétés modernes c'est la conjugaison
éventuellement
conflictuelle de deux fuites en avant
une fuite en avant capitaliste dans une
accumulation de marchandise en vue du
profit et une fuite en avant
technocratique dans des grands projets
en vue de la puissance y compris
coloniale et cette croissance des
marchandises et des grands projets
génèent une décroissance formidable des
espèces vivantes et des conditions de
notre vie sur Terre une décroissance
très inquiétante des droits des
travailleurs sur leur lieu de travail
une décroissance de l'acès une
alimentation de qualité à des transports
de proximité de qualité logement de
qualité un air de qualité à des soins de
qualité une éducation de qualité et une
décroissance des liberté
publique le refus de cette décroissance
des droits et de l'accès aux biens et
services surtout dans les catégories
populaires qui en sont les premières
victimes conduit la classe dirigeante à
dévoyer ce refus dans la désignation
d'un bouc émissaire les immigrés les
musulmans nous sommes actuellement en
pleine hystérie médiatique et
politicienne à ce propos et dans
l'insturation d'un d'un État fort
criminalisant les mobilisations
concrètes contre la décroissance de nos
droits la décroissance de notre accès au
bienens et services fondamentaux la
décroissance des conditions de notre vie
heureuse sur la
planète la croissance de l'extrême
droite son accueil dans l'arc
républicain inimaginable il y a à 20 ans
sont évidemment le résultat de cette
fuite en avant tant économique que
politique la criminalisation
desmobilisation contre la décroissance
de nos droits et de la satisfaction de
nos besoins fondamentaux est menée avec
d'autant plus de vigueur que l'adhésion
à la production telle que nous est telle
qu'elle nous a imposé par la double
logique du profit et de la
puissance cette adhésion est de plus en
plus réduite on pense à tous ces jeunes
nombreux à refuser d'inscrire leur
travail dans l'impasse de la marchandise
capitaliste ou du grand projet absurde
ce que j'attends du débat de ce soir
c'est que nous avancions ensemble dans
l'énoncer des voies par lesquelles nous
allons mettre la production sur ses
pieds les citoyens travailleurs la
sortir de la folie en finir avec
l'accumulation de marchandises
capitalistes et les addictions mortifère
qu'elle génè en finir avec les grands
projets absurdes et la volonté de
puissance nationaliste qu'il
flat enfin faire croître l'accès de tous
à une alimentation de qualité faire
croître l'accès de tous à un logement de
qualité un cadre de vie de qualité à des
mobilités de qualité à une culture et
une éducation de qualité un rapport
sensible au vivant et à la nature de
qualité et donc un travail de qualité
nous n'irons plus en traînant les pieds
contribuer à une accumulation de
marchandises capitalistes ou à de grands
projets AB sururde dont nous voyons bien
les conséquences négatives nous
déciderons ensemble des biens et
services dont nous avons tous et
égalitairement besoin et nous serons
enfin heureux au travail parce que c'est
nous qui en déciderons et ce que nous en
ferons sera conforme à notre déontologie
vive la croissance de tout ce qui permet
notre vie apaisée sur terre vive la
croissance de tout ce qui organise notre
responsabilité énorme de construire
notre monde selon un rapport réflexif de
raisons avec les autres vivants et le
[Applaudissements]
nonvivant j'espère que vous me
pardonnerez une réponse qui va être
beaucoup plus TER àtre euh au regard de
la question
posée
euh la donc moi je je pourrais ne pas
tenir 3 minutes et tenir 3 secondes euh
est-ce que la baisse du parc de machine
implique une décroissance du point de
vue physique la réponce est oui euh très
clairement parce que quand on regarde
historiquement ce à quoi nous ont servi
les machines elles nous ont servi très
exactement à l'inverse c'est-à-dire à
augmenter la quantité de flux physique
qu'on est capable de traiter euh avec
ces engins de travaux publicici et ses
grues l'ouvrier de la construction est
capable de construire de créer des
mètres carrés de bâtiments construits
beaucoup plus rapidement que à l'époque
où il y avait des pelles et des pioches
euh quand on regarde la quantité de
tonnes de blé ou la quantité de tonnes
de carottes qu'un agriculteur est
aujourd'hui capable de produire avec ses
moissonneuses batteuses ses tracteurs
ses usines d'engrais il est capable d'en
faire beaucoup plus par personne quasi
200 fois plus par personne quasiment euh
que il y a de siècles et ça c'est grâce
aux machines enfin grâce à cause d'eux
je sais pas comment il y a pas de
connotation positive derrière ce que je
suis en train de raconter c'est
simplement factuel euh le marin moderne
qui pilote un bateau à moteur il est
capable de transporter beaucoup plus de
marchandises que le galérien de l'ancien
temps la puissance d'une galère de
l'ancien temps c'était quelques dizaines
de kilos wat la puissance d'un bateau de
la marine marchande moderne c'est
quelques dizaines de mgaw donc on a
gagné un facteur 1000 et je pourrais
énoncer comme ça voilà le le tout tout
tout tout tout tous les flux physiques
qu'on peut regarder donc tout ce qui se
mesure en mètres carré en litrees en
tonnes en kilwh et cetera quand vous
regardez la manière dont ça a évolué
depuis que nous vivons dans l'air des
machines vous vous rendez compte que ça
a été affecté par des coefficients
multiplicatifs absolument
extraordinaires et comme je parle sous
le contrôle de mon voisin de gauche la
la les revenus ça n'est rien d'autre
monétairement que la production hein
c'est la même chose euh ça veut dire que
cette augmentation considérable de la
production a créé une augmentation
considérable des revenus matériels
l'augmentation considérable des revenu
matériels on la doit essentiellement aux
machines alors une fois que j'ai dit ça
est-ce que la baisse forte du nombre de
machines va baisser les flux physiques
la réponse est oui donc ça sera plus
difficile de faire un MT carré de
logement ou de déplacer une tonne d'un
point A à un point B dans un monde avec
de moins en moins de machine c'est
absolument évident est-ce que ça veut
dire que derrière ça implique la
décroissance sans complément d'objet bah
non la décroissance sans complément
d'objet moi je ne suis pas capable là je
vais rester très trivial je suis pas
capable de dire ce que ça recouvre donc
décroissance physique je comprends euh
décroissan du nombre d'espèces aussi ça
je comprends décroissan ou croissance
monétaire bah ça en fait ça dépend
essentiellement de ce qu'on a envie d'en
faire euh parce que pour passer de la
production dite en volume à au au au
produit intérieur brut qui est le grand
Alpha et Oméga et le grand Graal
aujourd'hui d'à peu près tout débat
économique euh il faut passer par une
case Inter intermédiaire qui s'appelle
la correction de l'inflation et la
correction de l'inflation aujourd'hui
est impossible à faire autrement qu'avec
des règles conventionnelles je m'étais
amusé à faire un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur j'adore ça je m'étais amusé à
faire un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur si on considère qu'il y a
quelques milliards de produits
disponibles à la consommation finale
dans le monde moderne et il y a 10
personnes à l'INC pour faire la
correction de l'inflation à supposer
qu'il ne dorment jamais donc qui
travaille H24 et qui ne prenne jamais de
vacances ça fait une fraction de seconde
par produit pour faire la correction de
l'inflation bien évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui n'est absolument pas
fait j'ai envie de dire produit par
produit c'est fait avec des conventions
donc si on accepte l'idée que on
supprime la notion d'inflation il y a
strictement aucun problème pour que avec
moins de machine on puisse avoir plus de
croissance économique ça pose aucun
problème par contre en sur le plan
purement physique j'insiste là
malheureusement c'est une donnée
d'entrée avec moins de machine on aura
une production physique qui va baisser
et ça se constate déjà dans les pays qui
sont aujourd'hui en en décroissance
subie de leur approvisionnement
énergétique c'est-à-dire de leur parc de
machine au travail et de très très beaux
exemples enfin très beaux eux ils vont
pas trouver ça très beau mais des
exemples malheureusement très parlants
qu'on peut observer juste à côté de chez
nous c'est toute l'Europe du Sud euh qui
était extrêmement dépendante du pétrole
le pétrole représentait la moitié de
l'approvisionnement énergétique primaire
de l'Italie de l'Espagne et du Portugal
avant 2008 et le retournement de l'offre
sur le pétrole conventionnel depuis 2008
a engendré dans tous ces pays-là et en
Grèce également euh une décru depuis
2008 ou une un arrêt de la hausse du PIB
le pays le plus spectaculaire c'est la
Grèce et c'est pas parce que les Grecs
payent pas leurs impôts ça rien à voir
avec ça qui paye ou qui paye pas enfin
je veux dire qui les paye ou qui les
paye pas c'est juste une affaire de
redistribution ça ça ça n'impacte pas ce
que je viens de dire voilà donc dans
alors donc en Grèce
où on va dire le PIB suit le flux
physique ben depuis 2008 le PIB décroit
en Italie c'est pareil avec les résult
résultat politiqu que l'on peut observer
voilà donc dans un monde avec moins de
machine oui les flux physiques vont
décroître et j'insiste ça sera plus
difficile d'obtenir un objet manufacturé
quel qu'il soit voilà alors après est-ce
que tous les objets pour rebondir sur ce
qui vient d'être dit est-ce que tous les
objets sont indispensables à notre
bonheur ça c'est un autre débat on verra
ça dans les questions
suivantes alors quel serait l'impact sur
les inégalités sal des trajectoires de
de transition sans modification du
système actuel le salaire attaché à la
personne n'est-il pas une des conditions
de la
bifurcation alors puisqu'on intervertit
l'ordre à chaque question euh là nouveau
alors je vais je c'est difficile pour
moi enfin je veux dire j'ai pas de
religion sur la façon dont l'avenir va
se présenter de ce point de vue parce
que je pense qu'il reste raisonnablement
ouvert par contre ce qu'on peut
constater sur le passé à nouveau là je
vais quelques observations
entre euh 1900 et 2000 et 1980 plus
exactement au moment des chocs
pétroliers et c'est pas un hasard euh
les inégalités en France ont
considérablement baissé euh quand on
regarde la part du patrimoine qui était
détenu par les 1 % des Français les plus
riches c'était plus de la moitié en 1900
c'est-à-dire qu'en 1900 les 1 % les plus
riches des Français détenaient plus de
la moitié du patrimoine des Français
et euh c'est descendu au tiers de cette
valeur euh aux alentours des chocs
pétroliers entre le tiers et le quart de
cette valeur et depuis les chocs
pétroliers ça a commencé à remonter ce
qui veut dire que tant qu'on était en
approvisionnement croissant d'énergie
par personne en France tant que le parc
de machine par personne augmentait en
France et c'est ça qui a permis
l'émergence des classes moyennes les
inégalités baissaient et depuis que
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
français s'est arrêté d'augmenter
c'est-à-dire depuis 1980 à cause des
chocs pétroliers et bien les inégalités
remontent elles ne sont pas du tout
remontées au stade où elles étaient en
1900 mais elles remontent et sur le
salaire c'est exactement pareil enfin
sur les revenus plus exactement pardon
pas les salaires donc salair et rent
c'est exactement pareil c'est-à-dire
qu'en 1900 les 1 % des Français
disposant des plus haut revenus captait
un/4 des revenus de l'ensemble du pays
euh et en 1980 c'était descendu à 8 % et
puis depuis c'est remonté également
c'est-à-dire que en fait historiquement
ce qui s'est passé c'est que la hausse
de l'approvisionnement énergétique
c'est-à-dire du parc de machine par
personne a fait baisser les inégalités
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui se
constate dans le passé alors à l'avenir
dans un monde qui va se retrouver en
contraction énergétique c'est évident
que si on y prend pas garde et donc moi
je vais finir sur une interrogation et
pas sur une affirmation c'est évident
que si on y prend pas garde il y a un
risque évident que les inégalités se
mettent à augmenter ça me paraît très
clair
dans ta question dan il y a déjà quand
même un point de vocabulaire tu parles
de
transition je ne crois pas qu' de
transition il faut une
rupture bifurcation une redirection mais
certainement pas une
transition si chaque fois que j'achète
j'achète pas au
demeurant une vocale de Nutella Ferrero
planton arbre ralbol
d'accord
je il n'y a aucune avenir à la
transition écologique seu la sortie du
capitalisme nous sortira des impasses
dans laquel nous
sommes alors sans modification du
système actuel il est clair
que ce sont d'abord les plus vulnérables
qui seront éliminés ou davantage
exploités
donc est-ce que le salaire attaché à la
personne est une des conditions de la
bifurcation réponse oui
aucune possibilité de
rupture démocratique en matière de
d'écologie tant que les droits nos
droits économiques seront attachés à
notre performance sur le marché du
travail ou sur le marché des biens et
services tant que nos
droits nos salaires nos
bénéfices seront en
fonction de la
performance dans la produc de valeur
dans ce cas-là évidemment nous sommes
engagés dans une logique du toujours
plus dont on ne peut pas se
sortir et puis si nos droits dépendent
de notre contrat de travail et non pas
et ne sont pas attachés d'autres
personnes si c'est notre contrat qui
décide notre salaire notre rémunération
alors nous sommes sous le chantage de
l'entreprise et aucune mais aucune
bifurcation écologique n'est possible
tant qu'il y a une possibilité de
chantage de l'entreprise sur les
travailleurs moi je dirais pas faire la
morale écologique à des travailleurs qui
défendent leur emploi fut-til totalement
désastrux de point de vue écologique si
leurs droits dépendent de leur emploi
donc il s'agit d'en finir avec le fait
que le salaire soit attaché à l'emploi
ou à la performance sur le marché des
biens et services sagissant des
travailleurs indépendants et la bonne
nouvelle c'est que le tiers des plus de
18 ans a déjà un salaire lié à sa
personne
vous avez les 6 millions et demi de
fonctionnaires c'est la définition de la
fonction publique c'est pour ça que les
fonctionnaires ont conservé 100 % de
leur salaire pendant le confinement quoi
qu'il ai fait certain NT plus travaillé
plus travaillé les les soignantes mais
d'autres est dans la situation d'un peu
tout le monde c'està-dire travailler
beaucoup moins ils sont conservés 100 %
de leur salaire parce qu'un
fonctionnaire n'est pas payé pour ce
qu'il fait c'est c'est un nous sommes
sortis de la logique capitaliste qui
nous paye pour ce que nous faisons
puisque comme nous ne décidons de rien
au travail nous ne sommes payés qu'après
avoir posé l'acte de subordination le
salaire à la tâche c'est le cœur de la
rémunération capitaliste là nous avons
commencé par toute la bataille syndicale
du 20e siècle à sortir de cela à lier le
salaire à la personne et non pas à la
tâche qu'il fait c'est le cas des
fonctionnaires 6 millions et demi de
fonctionnaires c'est le cas de la moitié
des retraité hein sur les 17 millions de
retraités il y en a u qui ont une
pension supérieure ou égale au SMIC
parce parce que en dessous du SMIC on
peut pas parler de salaire évidemment
mais
euh la la pension était construite c'est
tout l'enjeu de la réforme des pension
que de l'EN finir avec cela elle étaé
construite en 46 comme la continuation
d'un salaire non pas comme la
contrepartie de cotisation la la la
pension c'est pas j'ai cotisé j'ai droit
c'est comme retraité je n'ai plus besoin
de faire allégance à un employeur pour
être titulaire de mon salaire la
retraite c'est la poursuite d'un salaire
de référence c'est comme ça qu'elle
était construite en 46 contre les
pratiques antérieures qui faisaient de
la retraite la enfin le différé de
cotisation
et aujourd'hui encore sur les 340
milliards de retraite 250 sont calculer
sans tenir aucun compte des cotisations
c'est un salaire continué qui dissocie
le salaire de l'emploi pour l'attribuer
à la personne ajoutons les salariés à
statutin qui ont été dans le statut été
copi sur la fonction publ à le dfgdf à
la RATP à la SNCF c'est tout à fait
significatif que la classe dirigeante
s'attaque à ces statuts les supprime
pourquoi parce que il faut pour qu'elle
puisse encore une fois nous tenir dans
des activités avec lesquelles nous
sommes de plus en plus en
désaccord pour des raisons à la fois
écologiques et
anthropologiques évidemment il faut
qu'elle ne que nous ne soyons payés
qu'après avoir posé l'acte de
subordination et que nous ayons un
salaire à la mesure même de cet acte de
subordination nous avons inventé tout à
fait autre chose le tiers des plus 18
ans 17 millions sur les sur les 50
millions de plus 18 ans que nous sommes
a déjà un salaire lié à la personne
passons à 100 % le salaire doit devenir
le fait de tous les majeurs tout le
monde à 18 ans doit devenir titulaire du
premier niveau de
qualification 1800 € puisque c'est le
SMIC revendiqué net et pouvoir
progresser au cours de sa vie euh par
des épreuves de qualification en en
salaire mais dans la limite de 100000 €
hein nous pensons à réseau salariat que
un rapport de 1 à 3 euh est bien
suffisant euh pour organiser la la
production et que au-delà de 5000 € par
mois en dehors d'emmerd de monde je pas
très bien ce qu'on peut faire et donc la
la la la euh la le le salaire comme
droit de la personne comme droit de la
personne majeure c'est un enrichissement
de la citoyenneté
hein
la moi je trouve formidable la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et des
citoyens telle qu'elle s'opère en août
89 qui pose que dans une société
aristocratique où évidemment c'est pas
le cas chacun naît et demeure libre et
égau en droit et c'est sur cette base-
làà que va se construire la citoyenneté
comme abstraction hein qui fait que quel
que soit notre regégine sociale notre
diplôme notre couleur de peau nous
sommes postulé en capacité en
responsabilité de la chose publique sauf
que la bourgeoisie a exclu le travail et
la production de la choses publiqu à
dépolitiser le travail il s'agit au
contraire de refaire du travail le cœur
de la de la politique et donc d'enrichir
la citoyenneté de trois droits la
qualification personn ce qui n'est pas
le diplôme le diplôme c'est le travail
concret c'est ce qui nous permet de
faire télouter
l'activité la qualification autre chose
c'est le travail abstrait c'est la
reconnaissance que nous contribuons à
tel niveau à la production de valeur
économique il s'agit de nous poser comme
en
responsabilité du travail abstrait donc
de l'investissement des
choix d'inscription à la division
internationale du travail et cetera et
cetera nous devons et donc être 18 ans
et jusqu'à d'autres morts titulaire d'un
salaire qui exprime cette responsabilité
d'un deuxième droit qui est le droit de
propriété d'usage de tous les outils que
nous utiliserons car
comment être souverin à l'échelle
microéconomique si nous ne ce qui est la
condition de la bifurcation écologique
sortir de l'accumulation de marchandises
capitalistes et des grands projets
absurde ça suppose que nous que que que
nous prenions le pouvoir sur le travail
ça suppose au niveau micro économique
que nous soyons donc propriétaire
d'usage de de travail et puis au niveau
macro-économique que ce soit nous en
tant que citoyens qui décidion de la
création monétaire qui décidion des
accords internationaux en matière de de
de division internationale du travail
qui décidi des investissements en
matière territorial selon des procédures
démocratiques à inventé mais le
l'enrichissement de la citoyenneté est
absolument nécessaire au demeurant pour
éviter que la crise dans laquelle elle
est aujourd'hui le fait que les jeunes
et les catégories populaires ne votent
plus permettent soit l'occasion pour la
classe dirigeante de sortir son joker
fasciste ce qui est toujours le cas
quand il y a trouble dans la
citoyenneté merci
Bernard alors tu gardes la parole pour
la troème question quels sont les
besoins de reconversion et de formation
pour transformer for l'emploi faut-il
travailler plus dans un monde contraint
en énergie ou bien répartir le travail
pour créer un emploi pour tous à l'heure
où des initiatives sont lancées pour la
semaine des 4
jours non le problème c'est pas l'emploi
pour tous l'emploi pour tous c'est la
subordination pour tous n ne sortirons
pas de la fuite en
avant qui nous mène à un désastre
écologique avec de l'emploi pour tous
c'est salaire pour tous d'accord droit
économique ne dépendant pas du contrat
de travail ça c'est absolument
fondamental le
le nous ne prendrons le pouvoir sur le
travail ce qui est au cœur de toute
bifurcation écologique que si encore une
fois nous sommes titulaires de nos
droits économiques s'ils ne dépendent
pas du contrat que nous passons avec une
entreprise
deuxièmement tel que la question est
posée on a l'impression qu'on dirait
vers moins de travail moi je récuse
totalement l'idée de pénurie de
travail ENF qui est pénurie d'emploi que
la classe dirigeante organise la pénurie
d'emploi pour peser sur les droits des
travailleurs c'est tout à fait évident
mais pénurie de travail ça veut rien
dire il faut augmenter le travail vivant
alors que le capitalisme le remplace par
le travail mort alors avec des bénéfies
incontestables en terme de pénibilité du
travail et cetera de quantité produite
mais avec ce remplacement du travail
vivant par le travail mort en matière
agricole ce que la FNSEA et beaucoup
trop de chercheurs en agronomie nous
prépare une agriculture sans paysan
c'est un désastre écologique
anthropologique assuré il faut au
contraire augmenter le travail vivant
dans la production et puis il faut des
changements majeurs dans le
travail moins pour l'activité immédiate
de production
parce que une pomme produite dans des
conditions de de de de de de de respect
du
métabolisme de avec le vivant et la
nature est infiniment plus prod plus
nutritive que 30 32 pommes industrielles
on va donc produire beaucoup moins de
pommes pour des qualités nutritives
supérieures et avec plus de travail
vivant parce que pour faire une pomme
dans des conditions de de de de de de de
encore une fois de symbiose avec la
nature il faut beaucoup plus de travail
vivant que pour faire 32 pommes
industrielles donc il faut moins pour
l'activité immédiate de production mais
beaucoup plus pour la délibération du
contenu de la production donc dans le
temps de travail il va falloir inclure
la délibération sur le contenu de la
production l'évaluation de l'outil légué
par l'entreprise capitaliste on va pas
on va pas le détruire
je je pense à toute la tout ce que
l'intranet de d'erbus pendant le
confinement le premier confinement a a
véhiculé de propositions des salariés
d'Airbus qui sont les premiers concernés
pour dire on va pas continuer
indéfiniment envoyer des des avion dans
le ciel nous sommes dans la modo
industrie sur Toulouse comment utiliser
ce formidable appareil euh de
l'aéronautique pour pour pour continuer
à envoyer des avions dans le ciel
d'accord mais euh mais mais pour
convertir l'usage de ces outils à
d'autres à d'autres finalités ça suppose
que le temps de travail inclut ce temps
de réflexion le temps du démantelllement
pour reprendre euh les les termes de ce
de cette ouvrage tout à fait intéressant
euh de de d'Alexandre Monin Diego
lanzivar et Emmanuel Bonet hein sur
héritage et
fermeture une écologie du
démantelllement et
euh comment nous allons démanteler ça
suppose que ça rentre dans le temps de
travail c la la la la connaissance des
conditions de production des intrant
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'ignorance
sur la façon dont les intrans que nous
introduisons dans la production sont
produites ça vient d'ailleurs de même
que comme consommateur nous ignorons
totalement comment ce que nous
consommons est produit tout ça est
source de Cabal de calamité aussi bien
anthropologique qu'écologique euh dans
le temps de travail il va falloir
inclure la formation nécessaire à la
décision
euh sur le recours ou non au partage
international des travaux euh il va
falloir introduire dans le temps de
travail la connaissance et la et la
formation concernant les pratiques de
rentabilité dans une autre logique que
le profit ou la puissance il va falloir
inclure dans le temps de travail le
travail de reproduction y compris le
fait que l'entreprise devienne un lieu
de construction et non pas de captation
des capacité des personnes il va falloir
inclure dans le temps de travail
l'adaptation à l'instabilité du du
vivant le rapport sensible avec les
vivants que nous avons perdu globalement
demain Aurélien CEN Gabriel Cohen
soutient une thèse absolument formidable
une thèse de géographie la vie sans les
vivants pour interrogation où ils dit ce
que nous allons essayer de penser dans
ces pages ce sont les obstacles et les
leviers à la généralisation de pratiques
agricoles qui remettrai en leur cœur la
relation à l'instabilité des vivants et
pour que nous puissions assumer
l'instabilité des vivant il faut que
nous ayons un salaire qui lui sa stable
parce qu'attribuer notre personne voyez
le le
le l'enjeu n'est pas de voir comment on
va se partager moins de travail pas du
tout nous allons enrichir
considérablement ce que nous appelons
travail je serai un peu moins
optimiste je suis désolé mais je serais
un peu moins optimiste euh quand on
regarde ce que les machines ont fait euh
du côté du travail euh elles ont divisé
par deux le temps de travail entre 1900
et aujourd'hui donc les 35 heur c'est
les machines les retraites c'est les
machines il y avait pas de retraite
avant les machines les études longues
c'est les machines il y avait pas
d'études longues avant les machines il y
avait que les rentiers qui faisaient des
études longues donc les aristos
euh donc il faut bien quand on regarde
la réalité physique c'est que avant les
machines les gens transpiraient beaucoup
que les 2/ers de la population étaient
agriculteurs et que le soir il venaient
pas dans ce genre de conférence donc je
parle pour vous et pour moi en même
temps hein ils ils étaient juste épuisés
sur leur couches
bon donc
donc il faut il faut bien voir que si on
a le temps aujourd'hui de se poser des
questions philosophiques pardon d'être
un peu provoque on le doit notamment aux
machines donc est-ce que dans un monde
où il y aura de moins en moins de
machines et de moins en moins d'énergie
on aura besoin de plus de travail la
réponse est oui ça ça paraît absolument
évident physiquement je j'entends
euh comment je je ne préempte pas le
débat sur la répartition entre rent et
salair communisme et capitalisme et
juste physiquement euh
moins de machine il y aura besoin de
plus de travail et même malgré ce plus
de travail on ne compensera pas la
baisse de production physique hein ça
veut dire que le travail sera par
ailleurs en terme strictement physique
payez moins avec le le faut bien voir
que tout bien qui existe aujourd'hui et
qui existait il y a un siècle une table
une chemise une paire de lunettes et
cetera vaut aujourd'hui 1 kil de viande
vaut aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 50 fois
moins cher que ce qu'il valait il y a un
siècle et demi en temps en termees réel
he c'estàd le temps qu'il faut
travailler pour se payer ce genre de
chos aujourd'hui c'est 50 fois moins et
ça j'insiste à nouveau c'est l'avènement
des machine qui a permis ça donc dans un
monde dans lequel on va avoir des flux
physiques en contraction euh je je je je
pense que la évidemment on va avoir
besoin de plus de travail on va avoir
besoin de plus de travail manuel euh on
va avoir besoin de plus de travail pour
organiser une forme de sovriété
collective euh on va avoir besoin de
configurer plein de choses alors dans le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française qu'on a fait au CHI project on
a essayé de regarder on a essayé de
faire de l'économie sans parler d'euros
sa que ça va peut-être faire dresser
quelques cheveux sur la tête ici mais
c'est exactement ce qu'on a essayé de
faire c'est-à-dire que on a essayé de
regarder comment est-ce que il fallait
réorganiser physiquement les activités
pour que ce soit compatible avec une
baisse de 5 % par an des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'est-à-dire 5 %
par an de moins de pétrole de gaz et de
charbon pour être très précis et
éventuellement de méthane et de
protoxyde d'azote ce qui concerne
notamment
l'agriculture et on a regardé ce que ça
pouvait vouloir dire sur les mutations
de l'emploi sur une partie des emplois
où on arrivait à dire quelque chose de
pas trop idiot parce que il y a plein
d'emplois qui vont devoir aussi changer
dans ce monde là par exemple les
enseignants c'est évident qu'ils vont
pas devoir enseigner la même chose dans
ce Mondel que dans le monde dans lequel
nous sommes aujourd'hui d'accord si on a
beaucoup moins de machines sur
lesquelles coder ben les enseignants qui
apprennent à coder qui sont un peu moins
nécessaires si on a beaucoup moins de
machines pour aller se déplacer à droite
et à gauche les enseignants qui
apprennent soit à fabriquer les machines
soit à s'en servir soit à proposer des
services à la base de ces machines ils
seront moins nécessaires et cetera et
cetera donc les enseignants il y en a
une partie qui vont devoir enseigner
différemment mais pour nous on n' pas
rentré dans les calculs euh le fait que
euh comment dire le les les
modifications internes au métier d'c on
a dit les enseignants on n'est pas
capable de dire s'il en faut plus ou
moins donc voilà par contre il y a tout
un tas de métiers qui sont associés
aujourd'hui à des filières productives
sur lesquelles enfin productives
matériellement j'entends euh qui sur
lesquels on a été capable de faire des
petits calculs d'ord de grandeur par
exemple la filière automobile par
exemple la filière agricole par exemple
certaines filières industrielles et
cetera et le calcul auquel on est arrivé
c'est que il y a au moins un quart des
métiers qui doivent disparaître ou se
créer dans un monde qui se décarbone à
la bonne vitesse sur les sur 4 millions
d'emplois qu'on a regardé il y a un
million d'emplois qui disparaissent et 1
million d'emplois qui sont créés en gros
évidemment pas dans les mêmes secteurs
alors ça ça veut dire qu'il y a à
l'évidence des besoins de reconversion
qui sont absol ent majeur et on a
commencé à aller en discuter avec les
grandes centrales syndicales françaises
et euh la question évidemment c'est
comment on fait comment on organise ce
genre de truc est-ce que on se contente
d'attendre que les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les filières en sortent
naturellement partant à la retraite et
puis on embauche les gens ailleurs mais
si on fait ça ça veut dire que dans les
filières dont on a de moins en moins
besoin on a des gens de plus en plus
vieux globalement peut-être pas
extrêmement c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur je sais pas il y a d'autres il
il y a des compétences alors enfin juste
avant là Bernard parler d'ermus des gens
qui fabriquent des avions dans un monde
qui se décarbone on a moins besoin
d'avion manifestement euh alors on a à
la fois besoin dans un premier temps
d'avions qui consomment beaucoup moins
pour conserver quelques avions et dans
un deuxième temps besoin de moins
d'avions qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens
qui savent faire des avions voilà
question est-ce qu'on leur fait faire
des train parce qu'il y aassz besoin
d'assez de train est-ce que on leur fait
faire des calculs de structure pour
faire autre chose je ne sais pas enfin
voilà donc et alors ça c'est euh là
aussi pour mettre les pieds dans le plat
malheureusement c'est pas un grand
problème théorique ce genre de sujet
c'est 1000 milliards de problèmes
pratiques c'estàd que on peut faire des
grandes théories si on veut sur la
reconversion professionnelle juste ça
n'a aucune portée pratique euh parce que
la reconversion professionnelle de
quelqu'un qui est spécialiste du flux
d'écoulement d'air dans les turbines
d'un moteur d'avion c'est pas la
reconversion professionnelle de
quelqu'un qui a une exploitation
intensive de maréchage voilà c'est pas
du tout la même donc c'est que des
problèmes pratiques et ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a pas assez de
vigilance il y a pas assez de temps qui
est investi dans dans la façon de gérer
ces problèmes pratiques et ces problèmes
pratiques de mon point de vue euh sont
des problèmes essentiellement de filière
c'est-à-dire que il y a des voilà après
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
a été dit tout à l'heure par Bernard
c'est évident mais ça je pense que ça
serait vrai aussi si les activités
étaient détenues par des OP enfin par
l'étatin euh à partir du moment où vous
avez des activités qui doivent se
contracter charbonnage de France était
détenu par l'État je crois c'est pas
pour autant que les mineurs ont sauté de
jint en l'air quand on leur a dit vous
êtes plus nécessaire euh donc je pense
pas que l'antagonisme entre capitalisme
et détenstion par l'état règle les
problèmes des gens dont l'emploi est
moins nécessaire voire plus nécessaire
dans un pays qui se décarbone voilà je
pense que c'est deux problèmes qu'il
faut un peu
séparer alors Jean-Marc la transition
écologique pourra-t-elle se faire de
façon
démocratique et quelles seront les
modalités de mise en œuvre et les
besoins
d'arbitrage alors le le mot démocratie
c'est la planche pourrie par
excellence je connais pas de mots plus
piégeux que le mot
démocratie si je peux me permettre
maintenant que j'ai franchi le
demi-siècle depuis un certain
temps la la manière dont je traduis un
débat pas démocratique expression que
j'ai entendu un certain nombre de fois
c'est un débat quel que soi les formes
dans lesquelles il a été mené qui
aboutit à une conclusion qui n'est pas
la bienenne en général un débat pas
démocratique c'est comme ça qu'il faut
le
comprendre alors si si j'essae de faire
de la philosophie à deux
balles ma définition de la démocratie
elle peut être soit très scolaire c'est
un système dans lequel les gens votent
voilà système démocratique mais à ce
moment la Russie est démocratique les
États-Unis c'est démocratique alors
est-ce que est-ce que on considère que
les États-Unis par exemple c'est un pays
dans lesquel les courants d'opinion sont
correctement représentés moi je pense
que non c'est vraiment un pays dans
lequel c'est le règne de l'argent roi
hein ça pour le coup je veux dire les
élections sont achetées par de l'argent
les campagnes coûtent une fortune une
fois que les élus les élus sont capturés
par une partie de leurs électeurs
fortunés le système est indirect enfin
bon un milliard de un milliard de de de
de travers dans ce dans ce pays euh et
ça empêche absolument pas le pays par
ailleurs d'être extrêmement violent et
inégalitaire donc le don don donc la
démocratie on peut en avoir une une où
on peut en avoir une une vision un peu
plus euh large j'ai envie dire euh c'est
un système dans lequel la consultation
des gens qui vont être partie prenantes
derrière à l'action elle est
suffisamment importante pour que ensuite
il y ait pas de frustration majeure et
que on ait pu avancer en entendant
toutes les personnes qui avait voix au
chapitre hein euh et alors je vais vous
donner un exemple la convention
citoyenne pour le climat pour moi c'est
c'est un exercice de démocratie c'est
voilà vous prenez des gens au sort vous
leur demandez un avis sur les choses
chose qui serait pertinente c'est un
exercice de démocratie
voilà donc est-ce que la transition va
se faire en étant démocratique alors moi
je suis pas un grand adepte du
totalitarisme donc j'espère bien que oui
euh le risque c'est que ça ne soit pas
le cas et le risque ça c'est que ça ne
soit pas le cas avec deux écueils qu'il
faut éviter le premier c'est l'écueil de
perdre trop de temps et qu'à ce moment
ce soit des chocs externes qui se
chargent de réguler la situation parce
que quand une situation est hors
d'équilibre elle le reste pas
indéfiniment hein euh or actuellement
nous sommes hors d'équilibre au sens
physique du terme donc de toute façon la
situation va se réguler et si on le fait
pas de nous-même c'est des chocs
externes qui vont s'en charger les chocs
externes c'est rarement des ferments de
grandes démocratie l'histoire montre que
en général ou alors en tout cas il y a
un bain de sang avant
euh pas très pressé et euh il y a un
deuxième écueil euh l'écueil c'est que
euh et ce que je vais vous dire est pas
anticapitaliste par nature mais c'est
une perversion euh claire que l'on peut
observer en ce moment
l'écueil c'est que dans la crainte de
voir un monde s'organiser avec moins il
y ait une captation par ceux qui sont au
pouvoir de la ressource résiduelle et ça
c'est une crainte réelle qu'il faut
avoir et que moi je peux observer dans
l'exercice de mon métier même si je suis
dans une sale société capitaliste je
peux quand même observer ce genre de
choses et je peux observer que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut être
extrêmement vigilant alors j'ai pas de
martinal nécessairement contre ça
aujourd'hui hein mais c'est clair qu'il
faut être très vigilant là dessus et
qu'il y a un vrai risque que la
transition se fasse de manière
inégalitaire parce que ceux qui
l'organisent c'est ceux qui sont au
pouvoir et ceux qui sont au pouvoir sont
nécessairement proche de ceux qui ont
des intérêts à défendre hein donc ça
c'est quelque chose sur lequel et encore
une fois je je suis tout à fait
capitaliste dans mon exercice de mon
métier aujourd'hui mais ça m'empêche pas
d'avoir un gros warning sur ce danger là
et qui à mon avis est un aussi un danger
très important donc il y a un danger
important si on transitionne c'est
celui-là et il y a un danger important
si on transitionne pas qui est de se
prendre tellement de coup dans la figure
que la société dérivera de manière
totalitaire je suis en total accord avec
ce qui va d'être dit à propos de la
nécessaire
démocratie dans la dans la bifurcation
écologique
et ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
voir quels sont les les les
moyens de de conquérir des
droits sur la définition de ce qui va
être
produit par les travailleurs eux-mêmes
ou par les citoyens
travailleurs parce que pour moi c'est le
cœurin d'une d'une rupture écologique
qui ne serait pas imposé par des choss
externes et qui donneraiit des résultats
absolument catastrophiques c'est tout à
fait
sûr
et il faut pour nous à réseau
salariat se se saisir de tous les débat
public pour avancer dans le sens de
proposition de
droit de définition de du travail par
les travailleurs
eux-mêmes et par les citoyens parce que
comme comme on le sait ce n'est pas
forcément les travailleurs de telle
branche qui peuvent décider seulement du
devenir de la branche il peuv être pris
dans une espèce de duubriss et de de
confort technologique qui fait que il il
il il faut aussi que les citoyens et que
les travailleurs en tant que citoyens
délibère
euh par exemple qu'est-ce que nous
proposons nous proposons euh nous
proposons la retraite à 50 ans comme
façon de conquérir des droits la
retraite à 50 ans la retraite c'est pas
du tout la fin du travail hein la
retraite c'est le fait que la
qualification qui était celle du poste
devient celle de la personne et que le
salaire qui était jusqu'ici attribué au
poste devient attribué à la personne
alors pas encore suffisamment hein le le
le la continuation du salaire dans la
pension n'est pas encore suffisante mais
c'est tout à fait significatif que ce
droit a été conquis euh et c'est normal
qu'il soit combattu avec la plus grande
détermination par la classe dirigeante
qui veut que la pension soit différé de
cotisation et non pas la poursuite d'un
salaire et bien
euh faisons la retraite à 50 ans
pourquoi parce que à 50 ans c'est le
moment où on devient seniorin c'est le
moment où on na plus droit à la
formation professionnelle continue c'est
le moment où on est les premiers
concernés par les licenciements c'est le
moment où et si on on est licencié à
plus de 50 ans retrouver un CDI
respectant la convention collective
c'est quasiment impossible à temps temps
plein c'est le moment où on est invité à
devenir auto-entrepreneur par comme
Salarier en coûte trop cher c'est le
moment où on se retrouve imposé dans des
dans des CDD
ou du temps
partiel à à 60 ans hein à 60 il n'y a
plus que 52 % des personnes qui sont
dans l'emploi et les autres sont pas
sont pas retraités he il y a 7 % de
retraité seulement les autres sont
vulnérables sur le marché du travail et
exercent une pression à la paix sur les
droits de tous tout comme les jeunes ont
été inventés l'insertion des jeunes
c'est une pure invention depuis 77 le
plan plan jeune qui permet à la classe
dirigeante d'avoir une une masse de
manœuvre les les 18 35 ans comme jeune
on est jeune très longtemps aujourd'hui
hein euh euh qui n'ont pas accès au
salaire de la convention collective et
qui sont vulnérables sur le marché du
travail et donc il faut bien sûr
supprimer les jeunes supprimer les
jeunes c'est le salaire à 18 ans bien
sûr hein c'est le salaire à 18 ans mais
supprimer les
seigneurs mon père disait toujours dans
vieux au moyave tandis que dans Seigneur
il y a silité
euh supprimer les seigneors ça suppose
donc que à 50 ans on devienne titulaire
de son salaire porter au salaire moyen
la CGT r vendi qu'on double son salaire
pendant la vie pourquoi pas ça veut dire
salaire moyen à 50 ans le salaire moyen
c'est 2500 € par mois donc il est le
salaire qui sera inférieur à 2500 net
est porté à 2500 à 2500
€ ramener à 5000 s'il est supérieur à
5000 pour la raison que j'ai ditite
euh ce qui fait une hiérarchie de 1 à 2
des salaires à partir de 50 ans c'est
commence à devenir déjà plus
raisonnable et ces retraités sont
inlicenciables un peu comme le sont les
les les délégués syndicaux aujourd'hui
les représentant du personnel
euh pourquoi parce qu'ils vont être
chargés d'une responsabilité hein ils
sont en pleine possession de leur moyen
professionnel exaspérés de pas pouvoir
les exercer correctement bien ils vont
euh être chargés de l'autogestion dans
l'entreprise titulaire de son salaire
inlicenciable et chargé de s'opposer aux
directions et aux
actionnaires dans la conquête de la
maîtrise du travail c'est voilà un
exemple he de ce que peut être une une
proposition qui est une proposition de
conquête de
droit pour la maîtrise du travail par
les travailleurs vous avez la
proposition que vient de faire la la CGT
de
radar où il s'agit de bah de de de de
faire faire à la fois une enquête et et
et pas qu'une enquête enfin une une
habituation de réflexion dans les
entreprises sur les les enjeux
écologiques de ce qu'on fait étudier la
dissonance cognitive qu'il peut y avoir
pourquoi comment et cetera euh et et
conquér du
pouvoir dans la le fait de faire valoir
que tel ou tel
euh production est totalement
anti-écologique c'est euh bah évidemment
Jean-Marc faisait allusion aux
convention citoyennes c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est tout à fait
clair c'est en matière d'éducation
soutenir les méthodes qui sont des
méthodes de formation à l'autonomie de
formation à la codécision je pense par
exemple au lycée autogéré he l'éducation
nationale accepte quatre lycées
autogérés c'est-à-dire sans direction
dans lequel les et les usagers et les
enseignants et le personnel administr
ratif
cirige le lycée et le lycée autogéré de
Paris est menacé de
disparition pourquoi parce que nous
sommes là au cœur encore une fois hein
de la construction d'une souveraineté de
l'apprentissage dès dès l'enfance dès la
jeunesse d'une responsabilité sur la
production et d'une souveraineté sur le
travail
bien
Bernard toujours à toi la transition
écologique permettra-t-elle de maintenir
un État providence assurant le
financement des retraites de l'assurance
maladie ou de la gestion du 4e
âge là on est vraiment dans
un dans un
ponosane dont il faut que nous
sortions la question c'est comment on
finance
toujours c'est-à-dire que cette question
elle elle suppose que il faut qu'il y
ait une production préalable pour que
l'on puisse distribuer des
ressources d'abord produire ensuite
distribuer et donc lorsque l'on fait des
propositions je sais pas quoi de hausse
des salaires ou de ou de hausse des
pensions ou de de dépenses de de de
production de soin on va dire sur quelle
production sur quelle valeur déjà
produite allons-nous les
financer ça c'est c'est l'aliénation
complète à la religion
capitaliste encore une fois le pouvoir
d'une classe c'est son pouvoir sur le
travail parce que le travail produit la
valeur et donc l'argent une classe
dirigeante n'a de pouvoir sur l'argent
que parce qu'elle a le pouvoir sur le
travail penser que le capital fait des
petits euh dans la sphère financière en
se passant du travail c'est une illusion
c'est du capital fictif et lorsque la
bulle éclate aussitôt les banques
mondiales on l'a bien vu en 2008 crée de
la monnaie à toutberzing et de façon
absurde pour euh euh sortir de sa de son
caractère fictif euh la monnaie euh de
la de la sphère financière donc le
pouvoir sur le travail c'est euh
euh dès lors que nous ne décidons pas
vraiment du travail c'est le fait que N
nous ne soyons payé qu'après la
production et nous sommes catéchisés des
l'ensemble moi comme prof d'économie à
l'université pendant pendant 30 ans
après je suis passé à la sociologie j'en
avais un peu rbol quand
même le le le le je connais le
catéchisme par
cœur on ne peut distribuer que ce qui a
déjà été produit euh et il faut une
avance en
capital sous la forme d'un
prêt soit d'un prêt par création
monétaire soit d'un prêt par les
propriétaires de titres sur les marchés
financiers pour qu'il y ait
investissement production et finalement
distribution de salaire là nous sommes
dans l'inversion capitaliste de la
production hein celle qui nous fait
croire qu'un acteur totalement inutile
et totalement parasitaire le prêteur est
nécessaire pour
produire nous avons fait la
démonstration et là encore je veux
insister sur le fait que nous ne partons
pas de
rien que la la la la classe fondamentale
qui est la classe des
travailleurs a conquis des déjà là
communiste si par communisme on entend
la souveraineté sur le travail le fait
dans en finir avec la fuite en avant
dans la marchandise capitaliste ou dans
les grands projets
absurdes nous avons conquis euh une
production de soins dans les années 60
sans aucune avance en capitale dans les
années 50 la production de soin c'est
quasiment rien les hôpitaux étaient
réservés aux insolvables jusqu'en 41
autant dire que c'était pas des lieux de
haute technicité et il y avait pas de
conventionnement avec les les soignants
libéraux donc il y avait pas de soins de
ville sauf pour les plus riches on part
de zéro à la fin des années 50 et au
début des années 80 nous serons le
premier pays au monde pendant plusieurs
décennies dans les classements
internationaux de production du soin
comment s'est fait ce miracle par une
avance en salaire le taux de
cotisation de sécurité sociale qui
additionne la cotisation salarié et la
cotisation employeur hein était de 33 %
du brut dans les années 50 ilne à 33 %
du brut du brut c'est-à-dire du salaire
direct plus les cotisations salarié
au début des années 80 il est de 55 % du
brut d'ailleurs il est toujours 55 % du
brut en incluant une antiotisation qui
est la CSG dans le compte c'est-à-dire
que le taux de cotisation a tellement
augmenté moyenant des bagares
permanentes sur le hausse du taux de
cotisation hein entre la fin des années
50 et le début des années 80 que la
caisse d'assurance maladie était doté
très richement d'un salaire socialisé
c'est une avance en salaire et ce
salaire socialisé a servi à
subventionner l'investissement
hospitalier la création des CHU la
transformation des hospices en
hôpitaux avec des liit actifs la
création des maternités la
transformation des hôpitaux
psychiatriques de l'aide sociale le
passage de l'Aide Sociale à l'Assurance
Maladie tout ça a supposé un
investissement absolument considérable
aucun appel au marché des capitaux aucun
partenariat public privé un appel mais
pas si décisif que ça au crédit public
de la caisse dép consignation et d'abord
une subvention de l'assurance maladie
les hôpitaux n'avaient pas à rembourser
et les soignants ne soyent pas ne
soignaient pas pour rembourser la dette
de l'hôpital les soignants travaillaient
pour soigner ce qui est tout à fait
différentin aujourd'hui où ils
travaillent pour rembourser la dette de
l'hôpital ils ont perdu leur pouvoir sur
le sur leur travail c'est les
gestionnaires qui décident des
protocoles à la place de la clinique et
cetera et cetera il y a donc un lien
très important entre la maîtrise du
travail et le fait de ne pas être
endetté avant même de commencer à
travailler ce qui est le cas du
capitalistme où on est endetté avant
même de commencer à travailler nous
avons fait la démonstration pour 10 % du
PIB parce que la santé c'est 250
milliards que nous pouvons produire sans
appel au marché des capitaux en
remplaçant les f fustil public en
remplaçant le crédit qu'il faut ensuite
rembourser hein et qui fait que chaque
fois que nous remboursons un crédit
d'investissement ben nous nous aliennons
davantage hein nous nous enrichissons
nos
maîtres nous sommes nous avons dépassé
le Fatom euh du fait d'être endetté
avant même de commencer à travailler
nous avons remplacé l'avance en capital
par l'avance en salaire et ben
continuons créons de la
monnaie sans
remboursement une monnaie sans crédit je
vous renvoie à à toute la réflexion que
nous menons à réseau salariat sur le
site he réseaualariat.info vous avez
aussi le stand de réseau salariat à la
sortie euh venez venez nous rencontrer
euh nous réfléchissons donc aux
conditions d'une création monétaire sur
laquelle nous serions souverain ça
suppose que nous retrouvions évidemment
une capacité de création monétaire mais
ça c'est parfaitement possible soit
parce qu'on quitte la zone euro pas
l'Union européenne mais la zone euro ce
que je sais pas ce que font les Suédois
par exemple soit parce que dans la zone
euro même et sans la quitter nous
inventons c'est tout à fait possible r
possible Bruno terré toute une série
d'économistes de la monnaie le rappelle
nous inventant un moyen de paiement non
convertible en euros mais qui nous
permet de retrouver une souveraineté
monétaire absolument nécessaire pour
pouvoir créer la monnaie correspondant
au à l'avance en salaire hein pour pour
avancer les salairire des 50 millions de
plus de 18 ans d'accord nous som 50
millions avec un salaire moyen le
salaire actuelle de 2500 € net ça fait
30000 € par an dans une fourchette à
l'ANT de 1800 € à 5000 € il faut 1500
milliards notre PIB est de 2400
milliards il faut qui est le revenu
disponible actuel d'ailleurs 1500
milliards nous allons créer ces 1500
milliards comme avance en
salaire
et avec ce salaire nous nous allons
produire les biens d'investissement pour
produire les biens d'investissement il
ne faut que du travail il ne faut que du
travail et de la nature bien sûr ça
c'est pour produire de la richesse mais
pour produire de la valeur économique il
ne faut que du
travail investir ça n'est que du travail
inventer des outils les créer ext des
matières premières créer de l'énergie ça
ça n'est que du travail pour qu'il n'y
ait que enfin pour faire le travail il
ne faut que des travailleurs et pour
qu'il y ait des travailleurs il ne faut
que du salaire la seule avance monétaire
nécessaire c'est le salaire nous l'avons
prouvé nous avons su le faire nous
saurons le faire nous allons abandonner
la question comment on finance sur une
production déjà faite nous allons
anticiper la production de valeur par
l'attribution d'un salaire à tous dans
la responsabilité de produire la valeur
ça suppose une école évidemment qui
éduque à la responsabilité ça suppose
des entreprises nous sommes en
permanence nous sommes nous nous nous
nous éduquons mutuellement en permanence
à la responsabilité
économique
merci on va enfin pas être
d'accord si on se j'espère qu'on va pas
se taper dessus euh si on regarde d'un
point de vue physique en fait pour
produire il faut essentiellement des
matières premières et une capacité à les
transformer ça c'est du pétrole
transformé par exemple s'il y avit pas
de pétrole on pourrait pas faire ces
lunettes quelle que soit la quantité de
travail disponible ça c'est aussi du
pétrole transformé accessoirement et je
vais pas renverser ce ver sinon je vais
mettre partout mais ce ver en plastique
est aussi du pétrole transformé donc en
fait la pour pour produire il faut des
ressources naturelles et la capacité de
trans formation de ces ressources
aujourd'hui elle est essentiellement
faite par des machines donc pour pour
avoir des investissements faut des
ressources et des machines avant d'avoir
du travail aujourd'hui c'est surtout ça
qu'il faut le travail est devenu un
déterminant secondaire dans la
production mondiale des hommes enfin de
l'espèce humaine c'est essentiellement
ça ça a été fait par une machine he ça
aussi ça aussi ça aussi ça aussi ça tout
ça ça a été fait par des machines euh et
donc dans l'équation il faut surtout pas
oublier les machines parce qu'encore une
fois c'est elle qui bosse pour
l'essentiel
et du reste c'est elles qui ont fait
l'état providence l'État providence il
est né dans ce qu'on a appelé les 30ente
glorieuses mais les 30ente glorieuses
c'est l'approvisionnement énergétique
par français qui augmente de 5 % par an
c'est ça les trente glorieus c'est le
pétrole qui a fait le 20e siècle c'est
ça les trente glorieus sans le pétrole
il y aurait pas eu le 20e siècle il
aurait pas eu l'étr glorieuse et il y
aurait pas eu l'État providence je je
l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure mais je le
répète avant l'ère de l'énergie
abondante il y avait pas d'état
Providence ça existait pas l'état
providence physiquement c'est quoi c'est
la capacité des gens qui sont dit au
travail alors là par contre je suis
d'accord avec mon voisin de gauche ce
qui distingue aujourd'hui physiquement
une personne au travail d'une personne
pas au travail c'est parfois assez
subtileyz il y a des tas de gens ils
sont au travail assis sur une chaise
derrière un ordinateur et puis ils sont
pas au travail assis sur une chaise
derrière un
ordinateur physiquement vous faites
comment la différence entre un ingénieur
qui est en train de travailler sur Katia
et un ado qui joue sur Xbox je son en
train de faire exactement chose
physiquement hein sur le cul sur une
chaise en train de manipuler un clavier
d'ordinateur donc le la la comment dire
le geste physique associé au travail là
je suis tout à fait d'accord il est
devenu dans un certain nombre de cas
totalement indissociable des gestes
physiques ou totalement identiques à des
gestes physiques qui sont faits pas au
travail mais pour en revenir à la donc à
l'état providence l'État providence
physiquement c'est quoi c'est la
capacité d'un système productif global
parce que avant de distribuer C cette
lunette qu'on la donne qu'on la vende
qu'on la vende pour un prix symbolique
peu importe il faut avoir sorti le
pétrole et il faut une raffinerie et il
faut un vapor craqueer et il faut des
usines chimique hein sinon on fait pas
les lunettes là euh donc il faut bien
avoir produit pour que je puisse avoir
les lunettes ça c'est physiquement je
parle pas d'économiquement physiquement
c'est absolument évident donc l'état
providence c'est un système dans lequel
les gens qui sont dit au travail ils il
ils ils ils gèent un tel parc de machine
que ce parc de machine produit pour les
propres besoins des gens qui sont dit
travail et pour les besoins des autres
donc avant les l'énergie abondante et
les machines abondantes les gens qui
faisaient pousser des légumes les gens
qui faisaient pousser des patates les
gens qui faisaient pousser du blé et les
gens qui filaient le la laine ils
étaient pas suffisamment productifs pour
produire pour eux-mêmes plus une autre
personne qui n'aurait rien fait qui
n'aurait pas participé aux tâches
productif donc il y avait quelques
parasites les aristos qui participaient
pas aux tâches voilà il ripaillait et il
allait à la chasse mais ils étaient pas
très nombreux physiquement et ils
auraient pas pu être considér blement
plus nombreux parce que la la la
production de base elle était pas très
efficace bon arrivve les machines et à
ce moment dans l'airir des machines les
gens qui sont dit au travail peuvent
produire pour eux-mêmes plus tous les
gens qui sont en train de faire des
études plus tous les gens qui sont
retraités plus tous les gens qui sont
sans emploi plus tous les gens qui sont
à l'hôpital plus la construction de
l'hôpital lui-même et cetera c'est c'est
c'est suffisant les gens qui sont au
travail pour produire tous les autres
donc est-ce que dans la transition
écologique on va garder ça bah en fait
pour le coup c'est une question de
répartition alors dans un premier temps
la réponse peut être oui il faut juste
que les gens qui sont dit actifs
acceptent dans une contraction physique
de la production eux-mêmes voi leur
capacité leur pouvoir d'achat physique
se contracter parce que s'ils
l'acceptent pas ça se fait
nécessairement au détriment des gens qui
sont pas au travail physique là je parle
de physique hein je suis pas en train de
parler d'argent je suis en train de
parler de physique s'il l'acceptte voilà
donc s'ils acceptent d'avoir moins la
capacité de s'acheter des pots de
Nutella et des kinder Bueno ce sur quoi
on devrait se mettre d'accord c'est pas
du tout ce que les gens font en ce
moment hein je vous signale qu'en ce
moment l'inflation alimentaire touche la
baisse des aliments sains mais les
achats de Coca-Cola et Nutella ils sont
au même volume qu'avant hein donc c'est
pas ce que les gens font euh après il
faudra leur demander pourquoi euh quand
les gens font quelque chose qui à vous
vous paraît étonnant bah la première
chose à faire c'est d'aller leur
demander pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
sûrement très bonne raison de le faire
euh donc il faut le savoir et euh donc
donc dans un et si on naccepte pas ça
c'est-à-dire que si on a des gens qui se
disent nous qui sommes au travail on se
concentre sur nos avantages acquis et
donc on veut pas du tout être ceux qui
auront moins physiquement donc baisser
notre pouvoir d'achat en clair hein dans
un monde qui a globalement moins à ce
moment c'est évident que les gens qui
sont dits inactifs ils auront moins
beaucoup plus vite c'est absolument
évident donc la question de la
solidarité la question de la répartition
dans un monde qui va avoir physiquement
moins parce que j'insiste la transition
écologique qu'on la veuille ou qu'on la
veuille pas de toute façon d'une
certaine manière on va la voir
c'est-à-dire que la baisse des
ressources on va la voir euh et la
question dans cette affaire là de la
répartition de l'équité de la solidarité
euh sont sont des questions qui sont des
questions difficiles euh et là où on
devrait se retrouver avec mon voisin de
gauche c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est des
questions qui sont totalement
sous-explorées euh par le monde
académique euh et par les gens qui
réfléchissent c'est-à-dire qu'on ne se
pose pas la question de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on garde c'est des systèmes
euh solidaire d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire où les gens s'entraident
chacun tire pas dans son coin et où on
accepte de partager non pas dans un
monde qui a plus parce que distribuer du
rab deess setette n'importe qui peut
faire ça même moi j'y arriverai euh mais
dans un monde dans lequel il y a moins
et ça c'est un cahier des charges qui
est autre moins physiquement j'insiste
et ça c'est un cahier deschges qui est à
mon avis plus
difficile
alors Jean-Marc les sécurités social
sectoriell c'est-à-dire alimentation
culture redirection écologique défendu
par réseau salariat peuvent-elles
participer à la mise en œuvre du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
alors je vais avoir besoin d'une toute
petite explication de texte qu'est-ce
qu'on appelle les sécurités social
sectoriell c'est le fait c'est une
question
candide bien sûr oui c'est le fait de
poser dans d'autres productions que le
soin ce qui a
été mis en place dans les années 60 en
matière de production du soin
c'est-à-dire partir d'une d'une avance
en
salaire utiliser l'outil du
conventionnement
solvabiliser la carte Vitale c'est de la
c'est de la monnaie he mais qui est une
monnaie marquée comme on dit en économie
qu'on peut utiliser faiser le
conventionner c'est donc un outil de
politique publique considérable parce
que on on évidemment on va pas on on va
pas conventionner n'importe qui par
exemple en matière de lutte contre la la
la la la la la la folie écologieque dans
laquel nous sommes embarqués ben on on
ne conventionnera pas la grande
distribution par exemple de
l'alimentation ne conventionnera pas la
grande distribution on conventionnera
pas mass Ferguson on confona pas Bayer
enfin et cetera bien sûr c'est donc
donco si je traduis en
pardon pour des beau que j'arrive à
comprendre ça veut dire qu' j'auris
quatre cartes vitales dans mon
porte-cartte oui une carte Vitale carte
vitale qui te permettra une si j'ai pas
assez à manger non tu tu pourras
arbitrer comme tu l'entends dans une
carte vitale qui va être augmenté
d'accord mais et qui permet d'accéder à
plusieurs Ty de service qui te permet
d'accéder à des services d'accord pour
sortir aussi tous les alternatives de la
marge parce que tuas plein
d'alternatifes aujourd'hui en matière
d'alimentation de transport d'habitat
mais qui sont dans la marge pour les S
sortir il faut il faut évidemment
susciter un marché une
solvabilisation et tout l'enjeu c'est
évidemment les critères de de convenion
en terme pratique ça veut dire que ma
carte vitale me permet a c'est aussi une
carte Navigo et c'est aussi une carte de
distribution au resto du cœur en gros
alors pas resto du cœur parce que
justement pour éliminer l'aide
alimentaire et la remplacer par un droit
à l'alimentation pour tous hein mais
effectivement auprès de producteurs et
de distributeurs et de restaurateurs en
matière d'alimentation conventionné
parce que ils ne font pas appel au
marché des capitaux ils sont la
propriété de leur de leur salariés ils
produisent des bien euh respectueux de
notre survie sur la terre et cetera
voilà ok ok je comprends l'idée alors
pardon donc la question
c'était les
sécurité pardon les sécurités social
sectoriell défendu par réseau salariat
peuvent-elles participer à la mise en
œuvre du plan de transformation de
l'économie française d'accord alors je
vais commencer par faire un petit
disclaimer dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
euh on a évité on a été un peu lâche
enfin non on a été on a été prudent on
va dire dans un dans une V1 euh on s'est
pas attaqué frontalement à la question
des inégalités c'est-à-dire qu'on n' pas
euh on n'a pas regardé en quoi est-ce
que la réorientation sectorielle qu'on
proposait
euh était potentiellement ou pas
génératrice au sein même des secteurs
économiques concernés euh d'inégalité ou
comment est-ce qu'on traitait au sein de
la population le fait qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d'offres qui se
contractaient alors on l' enfin quand je
dis qu'on l'a pas traité frontalement
c'est pas tout à fait vrai euh parce que
on l'a quand même traité un peu par
exemple la réduction de l'offre de
transport ben on considère que ça
concerne prioritairement les urbains
plus que les ruraux parce que c'est plus
facile pour les urbains d'offre de
transport personnel pardon euh
individuel c'est plus facile pour les
urbains de basculer sur soit des
transports individuels sobres le vélo
euh soit sur des transports collectif
donc en fait on l'a quand même un peu
abordé cette histoire là alors moi j'ai
l'impression que la question elle
renvoie à ce que koworth là appelle la
théorie du donut c'est-à-dire que il
faut que la transition se fasse avec des
planchers sociaux et avec le fait que il
y a un certain nombre de besoins sur
lesquels la transition elle-même ne
conduise pas à acculer les gens dans des
impasses moi je considère que c'est ça
l'esprit général de la proposition j'ai
souscrit tout à fait alors après est-ce
que dans la mécanique proposée je
connais pas suffisamment dans le détail
les travaux de réseau ça pour avoir un
avis sur la question est-ce que dans la
mécanique proposée je serai d'accord
avec chaque virgule probablement pas
est-ce que je serai d'accord avec un
certain nombre de proposition
probablement mais l'idée que on est on
est particulièrement vigilant je l'ai
déjà dit tout à l'heure sous une autre
forme l'idée que dans cette affaire de
transition qui est quand même un grand
chambardement hein il on soit
particulièrement vigilant sur le fait
que ça soit pas une machine à créer trop
vite des laisser pour compte parce que
de toute façon c'est ça se retourne
contre la société elle-même si on fait
ça he c'est c'est c'est le le le
populisme qui monte et puis un jour ou
l'autre on se prend le truc dans la
figure donc le fait qu'on soit
particulièrement attentif à ça c'est
évident que c'est ça doit être un souci
premier hein c'est absolument évident du
reste on constate qu'aujourd'hui c'est
c'est pas anodin que j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure des Restos du cœur là où l'État
est défaillant souvent c'est le monde
associatif qui prend le relais et qui a
bien raison de le faire donc le donc
donc
d'être d'avoir des d'organiser d'une
certaine manière des offres de telle
sorte que globalement les gens ne
tombent pas en dessous d'un certain
niveau ou a toujours accès à un certain
nombre de choses essentielles euh oui ça
me paraît ça me paraît tout à fait je
sais pas je dois dire évident enfin bon
voilà après encore une fois est-ce que
dans le détail les proposition là je
dois confesser une ignorance telle que
je suis pas capable de les discuter euh
euh je suis pas capable de les discuter
précisément
mais je peux présenter un un projet
porté par un groupe de travail de de
réseau
salariat pour une sécurité sociale de la
redirection
écologique et et plus exactement des
travaux préparatoires parce qu'on
peut évidemment penser que pour que des
travailleurs vivent posi ement un tout
nouveau rapport à à l'emploi une autre
activité un changement de leur de leur
activité une disparition éventuelle euh
de celle qu'ils avaient pour passer à
une autre dans toutes les difficultés
que que de de formation et tout ça que
Jean-Marc a très justement souligné
euh l'idée que il soi titulaire de leur
salaire que leur salaire ne dépendent
pas de leur contrat de travail qu'ils
soi titulairire paraît une idée
favorable euh ça ça ça ça lève la
crainte
hein de perte de droit parce que
l'emploi va bouger hein tout ce qui
permet de dissocier les droits
économiques de l'emploi pour les
associer à la personne ça aide
évidemment à la l'abilité des parcours
euh sauf qu'il faut
vérifier euh que
euh ce soit un
un une proposition suffisante
et ce ce ce ce projet de de travail
préparatoire à la mise en place d'une
sécurité sociale de la redirection
écologique est porté par un collectif
qui réunit alors réseau salariat mais
aussi pour un réveil écologique Réseau
Action Climat l'Institut Rousseau
évidemment les shifterurs du groupe
d'exmarseille coorganisateur de de cette
soirée la fédération de syndicat
sectoriel printemps écologique
l'université Paul Valée de Montpellier
l'école spéri de commerce de Clermont
l'anacte et la CGT devrait bientôt
officiellement figurer dans le tour de
table des
partenaires ce projet c'est une
recherche participative qui sera
conduite en 2024 auprès de salariés
évoluant dans des secteurs identifiés
comme devant décroite par le ptef
donc par les les
shifters secteur du raffinage du pétrole
de la pétrochimie de l'aéronautique ou
encore de la construction neuve pour
prendre des entreprises de la région
marseillaise puisque c'est dans la
région de Marseille que cette recherche
prospective va être menée elle va
permettre de comprendre finement
pourquoi des individus poursuivent des
activités dont on sait qu'elles
hypothèquent les chances de maintien de
maintenir le vivant sur terre hein
comment ils assument cette dissonance
cognitive pourquoi est-ce qu'il l'assume
et par le le billet de questionnaire et
d'entretien semi-directif nous allons
vérifier l'hypothèse suivante le salaire
attaché à un contrat de travail et
impliquant un lien de subordination à
l'employeur et ce qui maintient
artificiellement envie des filières de
production reconnues comme étant
particulièrement nocivees alors ça fait
écho à d'autres travaux universitaires
ceux de de Daniel Priolo qui est
professeur en psychologie du travail à
l'université Paul Valérine Montpellier
qui a déjà démontré que le consentement
à l'exploitation au lien de
subordination prend la forme de contrat
de travail le salaire est un moyen de
rationaliser une dissonance cognitive
dans sa logique capitaliste sauf s'il
devient un salaire communiste
c'est-à-dire un salaire attaché à la
personne nous travaillerons cela avec
des étudiants inscrits en master de
psychologie sociale du travail des
organisations de cette université et
puis nous rechercherons aussi les autres
déterminants des freins à la redirection
écologique à savoir l'attachement au
métier à l'expérience à des activités où
sont développés des savoir-faire des
habilités
d'identité pour faire qui font que même
quand ce métier euh a des effets
écologiques désastreux on y a attaché
euh pour de pour de bonnes raisons euh
et ça c'est en écho aux travaux de de
Thomas coutr et de Coralie Perez hein
qui viennent de sortir redonner du sens
au travail une aspiration
révolutionnaire au seuil et qui font
partie de de l'équipe
qui
euh pense enfin qui qui qui raisonne
autour de C de cette
enquête une autre phase du projet
consistera à des entretiens collectifs
de salariés sur les dispositifs de
reconversion
existant et puis de comparaison des
différentes propositions de salaire à la
qualification personnelle celle dont est
porteur réseau salariat mais aussi la
proposition de la CGT par exemple de
nouveau statut salariés et de
sécurité sociale professionnelle et au
terme des débats ils proposeront ce que
serait leur sécurité sociale de la
redirection écologique idéal toujours
dans le même souci he qu'exprimait
Jean-Marc de la nécessité de de partir
des positions des propositions des
aspirations des inéressés eux-mêmes
cette phase du du projet sera réalisée
par des étudiants inscrits dans le
master stratégie et design de
l'anthroposcène sous la direction
d'Alexandre remonin qui est professeur
en redirection écologique et design au
sein
de l'école supérieure de commerce de
Clerm qui est à la fois le co-auteur
donc de héritage et et fermeture dont
j'ai parlé puis l'auteur d' d'un ouvrage
tout à fait intéressant qui s'appelle
politiser le renoncement parce que il
n'y a pas que l'énergie hein qui va
nécessiter des renoncements il y a l'eau
il y a le foncier il y a bien des des L
où il faut politiser cette entreprise si
nous voulons éviter soit des chocs
externes soit des entreprises des des
des États
autoritaires et la perte des libertés
publiques bien ben on arrive à la
dernière question et là tu vas m'en
vouloir parce que je vais réutiliser le
terme transition il va pas me tuer quand
même derrière le terme de transition n'y
a-t-il pas un retour d'aiguisé vers un
système économique datant des années 30
50 pardon moins de technologie plus de
ruralité moins de
transport merci cher Danis de te faire
l'avocat du
diable d'une proposition dont j'espère
que tu ne la partages
pas tu aurais d'ailleurs pu la formuler
de façon encore plus
stupide en le faisant comme Macron l'a
fait retour au modèle amiche si on ne
fait pas la
[Applaudissements]
5G je boucle ce propos introductif comme
je l'ai
commencé nous sommes embarqués sans que
nous l'ayons décidé sans que nous l' on
décidé dans la double impasse de
l'accumulation de marchandises
capitaliste sans réelle valeur d'usage
du type 5G
précisément au service du profit et de
l'imposition technocratique de grands
projets absurde du type Jeux Olympiques
divers dans le
désert au service de la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puissance la puissance et le profit deux
ingrédients de la dynamique de nos
sociétés font de cette dynamique une
fuite en avant mortifère et comme nous
le constatons aujourd'hui avec rage et
infinie tristesse sans cesse et sans
cesse
meurtrière la classe dirigeante nous
prépare à des gouvernements autoritaires
avec participation de l'extrême
droite quand on fait le bilan des votes
au Parlement pendant la précédente
pendant la l'actuelle législature
la majorité des textes ont été votés par
le trio Renaissance républicain
rassemblement national lequel votant ou
s'abstenant pour que la loi
passe cette dérive économique et
politique funeste peut-être
contrecarrée par une mobilisation pour
la conquête de la décision citoyenne sur
la production rendue possible
et je résume ce que j'ai mis en
avant dans mon
propos par l'actualisation et la
généralisation de deux conquis qui ont
commencé à nous libérer de la double du
double Fatom celui d'être endetté avant
même de commencer à travailler alors que
c'est nous qui produisons la valeur et
de nous soumettre au choix de prêteur de
perdre d'aliéner notre liberté au
travail et celui d'être soumis à au
chantage à l'emploi qui là encore nous
fait faire des travaux avec lesquels
nous sommes en désaccord nous avons
commencé à sortir de ce
Fatom avec l'avance en argent en salaire
à la place de l'avance en capital dans
la Sécur du soin étendons cela toutes
les productions avec le salaire lié à la
personne et non pas au contrat de
travail qui concerne des déjà le tiers
des plus de 18 ans et bien
généralisons-le à 100 % à cela à
l'occasion de tous les débats et conflit
il s'agit de de retrouver l'offensive de
sortir d'être en permanence sur la
défensive finalement à la merci de
l'agenda de la classe dirigeante il
s'agit de de construire aussi patiemment
et l'exemple du projet d'enquête sur la
sécurité sociale de la redirection
écologique en étin la la construction
donc
l'apprentissage de la codécision au
travail dans les entreprises et dans les
services
[Applaudissements]
publics donc la question si ma mémoire
est bonne c'est est-ce que la transition
ça va pas nous amener moins de technolog
plus de ruralité et moins de transport
[Applaudissements]
ouf pour le moment j'ai pas encore eu le
temps de répondre
alors sur le 3è point moins de transport
la réponse est oui parce que le
transport c'est de l'énergie je suis
désolé de vous faire un peu mal au crâne
mais e é= un demi de MV2 donc avec moins
d'énergie on transportera moins de masse
euh voilà c'est absolument évident alors
il y a des moins de transport qui vont
faire un peu mal et des moins de
transport qui feront beaucoup moins mal
euh aujourd'hui le moind de transport
qui fait pas très mal en fait il fait
mal à no à à nos problèmes de statut il
fait mal au problèmes de confort mais au
fond il faut pas il fait pas très mal
parce que l'essentiel des gens ont des
jambes euh c'est de passer d'engins de
transport individuel qui font une tonne
et demi à des engins de transport
individuel qui font quelques dizaines de
kilos euh ça c'est pas quelque chose ça
c'est j'ai envie de dire c'est un
problème culturel avant d'être un
problème
physique bon il y a un certain nombre de
gens qui font 50 bandes par jour pour
aller bosser mais peut-être que ces
gens-là la société peut s'occuper de
faire en sorte queils aient un emploi
qui leur plaise un peu moins loin que 50
bornes voilà donc on a on
a on a on a un sujet on a un sujet sur
le le là où ça va être beaucoup plus dur
dans le transport c'est dans le
transport de marchandises parce que le
transport de Mar les marchandises n'ont
pas de jambes et le transport de
marchandise quand vous regardez les
moyens qui sont employés il est déjà
beaucoup plus optimisé euh
énergétiquement que le dans dans un
camion le poids du qui transporte plein
de marchandises ce qui domine c'est pas
le poids du camion c'est le poids des
marchandises dans un bateau ce qui
domine dans un por conteneur c'est pas
le alors si le poids du bateau est
important mais c'est alors que dans une
voiture dans laquelle il y a une
personne ce qui domine c'est le poid de
la voiture donc il y a c'est beaucoup
plus facile de gagner sur les transports
de personnes sur le transport de
marchandis ça va être compliqué et donc
un monde sobre en énergie est un monde
qui va se démondialiser c'est absolument
évident et la démondialisation je peux
vous dire ça va pas du tout être bon
pour votre pouvoir d'achat mais alors
pas du tout du tout du tout du tout ni
pour le mien du reste
euh ça va pas du tout être bon parce que
aujourd'hui vous n'avez physiquement pas
un seul produit qui échappe à la
mondialisation dans son processus de
fabrication déjà on n pas une mine en
France pas une mine active on pourrait
en ouvrir quelques-unes une mine de
lithium ici il reste quelques mines de
fer ici on a pas de mine de cuivre on
avait un peu de boxide pas loin d'ci du
reste la
boxite il doit en rester un peu enfin
pas des gros paquets euh et cetera or
aujourd'hui l'économie physiquement
utilise les 92 éléments du tableau de
mandelf c'est-à-dire qu' il y a pas un
élément du tableau de mandelf qui est
pas une application industrielle
aujourd'hui donc c'est un monde c'est
clair que la transition au sens sobriété
énergétique c'est un monde avec moins de
transport et la monde un monde avec
moins de transport est un monde surtout
sur les marchandises qui va être un
monde dans lequel la production physique
elle va décélérer et donc elle va se
renchérir en terme d'heors de temps de
travail pour pour acheter quelque chose
parle pas de par pas d'arent est-ce que
c'est un monde avec moins de technologie
la réponse est aussi oui alors est-ce
que c'est un drame non moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord la 5G on aurait très
bien pu s'en passer du comme la 6 comme
la 7 et comme la pig et comme la 8 et
demi quand on voit à quoi ça sert avant
avant d'avoir la 5G les gens jouaient à
Candy crush au lieu de regarder
Instagram je suis pas sûr qu'ils étaient
fondamentalement de scroller sur des
vidéos je pas sûr qu'ils étaient
fondamentalement plus malheureux encore
avant les gens faisaient une chose
totalement folle ils lisaient dans les
transports en commun demande vraiment ce
qui leur passait par la
tête où il faisaent des sudocul euh
ouais ouais je pense que la baisse du
niveau en math dans ce pays est d à la
5G donc je suis sûr qu'il y a un rapport
alors non c'est en fait c'est ce que je
vous dis c'est pas une blague si vous
avez lu cet excellent bouquin qui
s'appelle la fabrique du crétin digital
euh de Michel desmurgers je vous conse
si vous l'avez pas fait je vous
conseille sa lecture euh vous en tirez
qu'une seule conclusion c'est attendez
le plus tard possible si vousz vous avez
des enfants pour que votre enfant soit
confronté à un écran vraent plus plus
vous chaque année de gagner est une
c'est voilà c'est c'est bon à prendre
euh donc si vous et puis il y a un autre
bouquin que j'ai préfacé qui s'appelle
algocratie dans lequel qui est un
bouquin qui porte sur les algorithmes
des réseaux
sociaux qui explique qu'en fait ces
algorithmes sont faits pour garder les
gens dans leur zone de confort et créer
du communautarisme c'est-à-dire diminuer
l'ouverture au monde et diminuer la
hauteur de vue des individus c'est à ça
que sert les algorithmes des réseaux
sociaux hein donc voilà donc le le moins
de
technologie moins de technologie je
pense qu'il y a des domaines dans
lesquels ça nous fera pas de mal
maintenant globalement c'est clair que
la sobriété énergétique va être moins de
technologie pourquoi parce que la
technologie c'est quoi c'est de la
complexification et de la rotation des
actifs physiques pour que le progrès
technique pénètre ça veut dire qu'il
faut que vous remplaciez quelque chose
que vous aviez par quelque chose d'autre
ou que vous rajoutiez à ce que vous avez
avait déjà quelque chose d'autre c'est
ça la pénétration de la technologie et
donc ça veut dire de l'énergie à la fois
pour fabriquer les nouveaux objets ou
pour les remplacer et dans un monde qui
devient sobre en étergie cette rotation
du capital physique elle se ralentit
donc ça veut dire que la technologie
pénètrera moins vite même si les
ingénieurs génnieiaux font des
trouvailles géniales cette trouvaille
géniale mettra plus de temps à diffuser
au sein de la population pour autant
qu'elle soit capable de diffuser et par
ailleurs la l'abondance énerg nous a
permis de complexifier alors là je suis
désolé je vais vous faire un tout petit
peu mal au crâne avec de la physique
vous avez en physique une grande loi
dans la thermodynamique qui est le deème
principe de la thermodynamique qui dit
que dans un système clos le la quantité
de désordre ne peut que croître au cours
du temps ce qui veut dire que pour
ordonner un système vous êtes obligé
d'exporter du
désordre c'est ça que dit le deè alors
je vous le traduis en termees
environnementaux plus vous fait au sein
de la société des hommes des dispositifs
complexes c'est-à-dire avec beaucoup
d'ordre à l'intérieur plus plus vous
êtes obligé de saloper l'environnement
et vous pouvez pas y échapper parce que
c'est le deuxième principe de la
thermodynamique qui vous dit ça ce qui
veut dire que si on veut moins saloper
l'environnement on va être obligé de
simplifier les systèmes qu'on utilise on
va être obligé de les simplifier et les
simplifier au sens classique du terme ça
veut dire moins de
technologiein alors ça veut dire très
concrètement des alliage moins
sophistiqué parce qu'ils sont plus
facilement recyclables ça veut dire de
l'électronique moins performante parce
que plus modulaire parce que on
recyclera des trucs qu'on utilisait déjà
il y a 20 ans et donc ils sont
performants comme il y a 20 ans et pas
performants comme aujourd'hui ça veut
dire voilà ça veut dire un certain
nombre de choses de cette nature est-ce
que c'est la mort non du reste ne pas le
faire ça veut pas dire que le monde va
pas bouger je l'ai déjà dit mais ça veut
dire effectivement qu'on aura moins de
technologie au sens où on l'entend
habituellement on aura moins de gadget
ça c'est absolument
certain est-ce qu'on aura plus de
ruralité alors là c'est pareil quand on
regarde d'où on vient la réponse est oui
c'est-à-dire que dans l'ancien temps
quand on avait des transports qui
étaient peu disponibles et bien
l'essentiel des gens devait être pas
trop loin de là où ça pousse parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on mange hein donc
dans un monde dans lequel les flux
physiques vont baisser la logique
voudrait que on ait besoin de dégonfler
les mégapoles donc personnellement je
pense que aujourd'hui tous les projets
d'urbanisme qui consistent à faire
grossir les mégapoles sont des trucs qui
vont nous envoyer dans des impasses ça
prépare de la désérance hein euh ça
prépare des populations qui vont être
économiquement insolevables c'est je
pense que c'est ça que ça prépare et ça
veut dire que il faut revenir à un
urbanisme avec des villes plus petites
et forcément un tissu rural plus
important voilà alors est-ce que là
c'est pareil est-ce que c'est une
catastrophe faut faut s'organiser de
telle sorte pour que la réponse soit non
et puis avant qu'on soit vraiment à l'os
je pense quand même qu'il va il va y
avoir du temps mais c'est c'est quelque
part il y a une forme de logique à ça
c'est-à-dire que encore une fois dans
l'ancien temps les besoins essentiels
c'est notamment manger euh ne pouvait
être assuré qu'en étant pas très loin de
là où était la production agricole ça
veut aussi dire incidemment qu'il faut
déspécialiser le monde agricole donc
dans le ptef on propose de déspécialiser
partiellement le monde agricole
aujourd'hui il y a un camion sur trois
en France qui transporte quelque chose
qui se mange dans un monde avec très peu
de pétrole c'est quelque chose qui ne
flotte pas donc ça veut dire que la
polilyculture élevage qu'on avait dans
l'ancien temps quelque chose qui
minimise les transports intermédiaires
dans le monde agricole hein et qui
rapproche les biens directement
consommables de la population euh c'est
beaucoup plus performant dans un monde
sobre énergétiquement que le modèle
qu'on a créé aujourd'hui où on a toutes
les grandes où on a fait des des un
modèle agricole de commodité à
l'exportation en gros hein donc on met
les grandes commodités dans des zones
très spécialisées dans le monde et on
s'en fout parce que on peut relier
toutes ces zones avec des bateaux et des
camions autant qu'on veut hein bah ça ça
marche pas dans un monde très sobre sur
le plan énergétique et il faut revisiter
ce modèle et revisiter un modèle
agricole c'est long parce que c'est
comme revisiter tous les modèles
culturel ça prend une à deux générations
c'est pas un truc qui se fait en 3 ans
ou en tout cas la version en 3 ans est
une version pas sympathique donc est-ce
qu'on va avoir donc la
réponse les trois items dans la question
la réponse est OUI à chaque
fois est-ce que et il nous appartient
d'en être conscient et de nous organiser
de telle sorte que ce soit vécu plutôt
comme quelque chose de sympathique et
pas comme un
drame
[Applaudissements]
bien euh maintenant la parole va être à
vous donc on va un peu s'organiser je
vais vous expliquer on a placé deux
micros un à droite un à gauche
euh au pied de de la tribune donc vous
vous déplacez vous vous avancez jusqu'au
micro on prendra une prise de une
intervention à droite et ensuite une
intervention à gauche quand on aura
trois interventions la parole remontera
à la tribune on fera en sorte également
que les prises de parole soit
paritaire au risque que Jean-Marc cesse
de répondre aux
questions c'est c'est un un homme une
femme dans les questions voilà donc faut
organiser les que au micro en
conséquence là je vois qu'il y a des
hommes qui se sont déplacés c'est bien
pour ça que j'ai fait cette
règle donc mesdames on compte sur
vous alors vous avez pour vos
interventions vous avez comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure vous avez 2
minutes et au-delà de de 2 minutes une
douce musique vous accompagnera dans
votre prise de parole alors on va
commencer par la
gauche on vous
écoute
bonsoir donc moi je voulais parler de
aurellio PCH donc président du Club de
Rome qui a commandé le le rapport
midose donc il disait en 1983 dans cri
d'alarme pour le 21e siècle il disait
que la transition allait être d'abord
culturelle qu'en
pensez-vous c'est à vous maintenant
c'est à une dame c'est une dame ah oui
ouais
non ça va
bonsoir ma question s'adresse
précisément à Monsieur jeancovissi mais
Bernard Friot pourrait y répondre aussi
euh à moins d'une heure de voiture d'ici
se joue au nom de la décarbonation la
mort de la forêt d'Els arbouffier cet
homme qui plantait des arbres sous la
plume de
jean-gonau la forêt de la montagne de
Lure est aujourd'hui détruite rasée
saccagée pour installer vous l'aurez
compris une centrale photovoltaïque dont
le bilan carbone est probablement
désastreux aberration écologique
énergétique esthétique et illégal
puisque ce site naturel est un site
protégé mais installation qui génère des
profits il semble que nous soyons là
face à un effet pervers des discours sur
la décarbonation dont vous ne pouvez pas
être
DUP ne pensez-vous pas qu'il est
absolument nécessaire lors de toutes les
interventions médiatiques de dénonc
systématiquement ce genre de pratique
qui dcervent le propos de la
décarbonation ou alors devons-nous
considérer que ces pratiques sont un mal
nécessairire et les
accepter on prend une
intervention à droite pour vous à gauche
pour nous bonsoir non non non non non ça
marche dans les deux sens là maintenant
c'est un homme non attendez ah pardon
j'ai j'ai qu'est-ce que non faut faut
faut être un peu sérieux quand même
écoutez très bien très bien après après
bonsoir donc question à Monsieur Friot
euh donc la bifurcation écologique que
vous proposer est en fait une révolution
communiste appropriation des moyens de
production collectivisation
autogestion euh clientélisation de la
population c'està-dire votre proposition
de d'allocation
universelle rend en fait les gens
dépendants de l'État c'estàdire du
verseur des allocations n'encourage pas
le travail et la production et là je
pense que monsieur janovissi a répondu
il faut d'abord produire avant de
redistribuer contrairement à ce que vous
affirmez et donc ça jettera la
population dans les bras de populistes
qui proposeront plus qui payeront plus
qui travaill voilà qui travailler encore
moins donc je ne vois pas comment vous
pouvez concilier votre proposition avec
la
démocratie et ensuite cette conception
du Grand Soir du grand
tournant n'est pas du tout en ligne avec
les comportements individuels qui
doivent changer et les comportte comm
collectif de décarbonation et de société
en fait votre proposition ne rend
aucunement les citoyens acteurs du
changement puisqu'il faut attendre la le
grand soir pour enfin pouvoir
agir alors la question c'est
euh donc quelle proposition concrète
avez-vous pour la transition écologique
aujourd'hui à part attendre le grand
soir
merci excusez-moi je juste peut-être
déroger parce que c'est une question qui
est dans la continuité c'est-à-dire
que non déroge pas non non bon ben alors
on y reviendra après alors
non parce que après c'est une
femme du coup ça marche
pas bonsoir et
merci c'est fini on a on a nos trois
interventions mais juste après c'est
vous juste après c'est vous mais ben du
coup moi moi je me suis fait couper la
parole c'était juste une question pour
la salle plutôt si si c'est possible
c'est c'est pas très compliqué ça peut
aller juste savoir dans la salle
peut-être en levant la main qui serait
prêt à bifurquer dans son métier par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit
éventuellement parce que je pense que
dans voilà je sais pas bah voilà du coup
si la question est simple juste
ou peut-être c'est déjà fait
effectivement quel point est-ce que la
réponse est
biaisée qui veut aller dans
l'agriculture une agriculture voilà
productive mais de bon sens ok bon voilà
c'était
[Applaudissements]
plus et ben Bernard c'est à
toi euh je crois qu'il y a une
contresens Tet pour la question qui
m''est adressé euh euh sur le grand soir
je suis euh je n'ai jamais prononcé ni
le mot ni la chosein nous sommes au
contraire hein dans
euh la la création d'alternative au
capitalisme dans le capitalisme lui-même
nous sommes à l'opposé de toute
proposition dans laquell il faudait
d'abord je sais pas quoi conqurire le
pouvoir d'État puis ensuite faire un
socialisme d'État et ensuite le
communistme je sais pas quoi c'est nous
sommes à l'opposé de cette de cette
vision hein il s'agit
aujourd'hui
maintenant de
euh de conquérir des droits de
souveraineté sur le
travail de conquérir un droit alors ça
donc dans les entreprises on a proposé
par exemple que à 50 ans chacun av une
titulaire de son salaire et soit un
licentiable pour organiser l'autogestion
contre les directions par exemple le le
le le le fait
aujourd'hui que nous devenions
titulair du salaire qui n'a rien à voir
avec la location universelle qu'est-ce
que c'est que la location universelle
c'est euh l'arme de guerre de la classe
dirigeante contre le salaire à la
qualification
personnelle la classe dirigeante ne
supporte pas que en tant que
personne 17 millions des majeurs soit
titulaire d'un salaire
qui reconnaî comme tout salaire leur
leur responsabilité et leur contribution
à la production de
valeur parce que si ce sont les
personnes qui deviennent titulaire de
leur salaire alors le le le le le
pouvoir sur elle qu'exerce une
bourgeoisie qui ne les tient plus par le
chantage à l'emploi disparaît donc il a
une obsession de la classe dirigeante en
finir avec le statut de la fonction
publique en finir avec le statut des
cheminaux des postiers en finir avec le
statut de le dfgdf en finir avec le
statut de la RATP en finir avec le droit
au salaire des retraités en finir avec
le droit au salaire des
chômeurs bref en finir avec le salaire
lié à la
personne mais pour restaurer le salaire
capitaliste qui est un paiement à
l'acte ce qui est le cas de toute
lubérisation par exemple la lubérisation
nous sommes au cœur de la logique
capitaliste des rapports de travail
paiement à l'acte mais dans euh les les
entreprises plus plus classiques que que
que uber ou desrou qui sont jamais que
le retour avant
1910 vous avez également une
multiplication des situations dans
lequell les travailleurs sont payés à
l'acte c'est la prime à la place du du
salaire de la hausse du salaire et
cetera et
cetera ce paiement à l'acte qui dépend
donc de la
performance sur le marché des biens et
services mais une performance qui est
pas
assurée va introduire une très
grande
insécurité s'il est général
is et donc pour que la paix sociale
reste possible malgré cette
insécurité il faut
absolument que nous soyons titulaire
d'un revenu de base inconditionnel qu'il
y a un filet de
sécurité la proposition de revenu de
base inconditionnel c'est la proposition
de la classe
dirigeante pour en finir avec le salaire
li à la
personne en aucun cas donc je suis le
préconisateur de la location universelle
quand à c'est pas du tout l'État qui va
payer qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire de paiement par l'État pas du
tout il s'agit au contraire d'une forme
de dépérissement de
l'État dans le bouquin avec L'Ordon qui
s'appelle en travail conversation sur le
communisme que qui est paru à la dispute
euh en euh en 2021 qui est à la
disponible sur le stand de réseau
salarial à sortie dans ce bouquin
lordordon et moi nous nous nous mettons
un qualificatif à des mots sur lequels
on en met
jamais valeur travail monnaie
répartition état et cetera et ce
qualificatif c'est c'est communiste ou
capitaliste l'État capitaliste on voit
bien ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui hein il
accompagne et les grands projets menés
au nom de l'écologie comme d'habitude on
détruit les forêts pour faire
euh du du du du du du photovoltaïque ça
fressos a très très bien montré hein
comment c'est toujours pour
l'écologie que les mutations
technologiques euh sont lancés et
s'additionne hein c'est pour sauver les
forêts qui a été mis en place le charbon
c'est pour sauver
l'atmosphère vicier des villes et cetera
qui a été mis en place le pétrole c'est
pour
sauver la la le le le enfin la nous
sauver de la production de CO2 que met
qui mise en place l'électricité
nucléaire c'est toujours pour des
raisons ou des trucs alternatifs du
genre photovoltaïque c'est toujours pour
des raisons écologiques que ensuite va
s'amplifier va s'additionner une
technologie nouvelle on n jamais extrait
autant de charbon dans le monde que
l'année dernière he il a donc pas c'est
pas c'est pas des des c'est pas du tout
des sources d'énergie substituables ell
s'additionne et toujours pour des
raisons
écologiques la la faire du
photovoltaïque à la place d'une forêt
euh c'est c'est euh je je je je pr le
train entre entre Bordeaux et Tarbe
récemment c'est affligeant ce qu'on
voit des forêts totalement de
monoculture qui ne sont qui n'ont aucune
valeur écologique d'accord et puis
d'immenses champ de de de de soustrait à
l'activité agricole pour faire des
panneaux solaires
enfin nous continuons la fuite en avant
folle
donc il
s'agit non pas du tout d'attendre je
sais pas trop quel grand soir ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est absurde il s'agit non
pas non pas que ce soit
l'état qui assume tout
cela ce que nous avons su inventer que
je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de dire mais
merci pour cette question qui me permet
de le dire c'est un état communiste les
prémisses d'un état communiste c'est
quoi c'est une fonction collective en
force de loi ce qu'on appelle en général
l'état assumé par les intéressés
eux-mêmes assumé par les intér c'est la
gestion du régime général de sécurité
sociale entre 47 et 67 gestion par les
travailleurs et il gérait plus que le
budget de l'État sans appareil
d'État c'est ça c'est cette démocratie
là qu'il s'agit de retrouver et de
généraliser nous n'avons pas besoin
d'appareil d'État mais nous avons besoin
de fonction collective ayant force de
loi dans
lesquelles dans la définition ENF dans
la géré par les intéressés eux-mêmes cet
enrichissement de la citoyenneté qui est
absolument nécessaire encore une fois
nous avons pas inventé la lune nous
l'avons déjà fait pendant 20 ans et si
la charnement pour supprimer la gestion
par les régime général c'est parce
que nous sommes au cœur là
du de la
sortie de l'accumulation de marchandis
au fin du profit
ou de des grands projets
absurdes avec le soutien de l'État
capitaliste c'est c'est nous avons su le
faire nous avons su nous en nous en
sortir nous saurons évidemment nous en
sortir
euh je vais essayer de faire rapide sur
les deux autres du coup euh sur
le sur le Club de
Rome euh si je suis tout à fait d'accord
que le la bataille elle est avant tout
culturelle au sens où c'est d'abord il
faut se mettre enfin il faut arriver à
se à se mettre d'accord sur un objectif
qui est physiquement réaliste et
socialement souhaitable euh et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est avant tout
culturel euh des deux côtés du reste euh
sur le sur le solaire et la forêt alors
euh pardon je vais rentrer un tout petit
peu dans la technique euh aujourd'hui le
but du jeu que nous nous sommes fixés
c'est d'essayer de se passer des
combustibles fossiles on a une première
raison pour le faire qui est climatique
et une deuxième raison pour le faire qui
est l'épuisement de ces combustibles on
peut remplacer une partie de ces
combustibles fossiles par des économies
c'est-à-dire que juste on en on utilise
moins d'énergie donc chauffe au gaz et
on baisse le thermostat voilà ça marche
ou bien on garde une voiture à pétrole
et on passe d'un d'une Land Rover à une
C1 ça ça marche aussi bon en général
c'est pas les mêmes mais c'est pas grave
ça marche quand même
euh après euh une autre manière de faire
c'est de passer d'une énergie carbonée à
une énergie décarbonée et là notre pays
c'est un fait pas la pas la peine de
faire l'histoire c'est un fait mais euh
pendant les 20 dernières années a été
très réticent sur le fait d'avancer sur
le développement de l'énergie nucléaire
donc l'énergie nucléaire dans ce pays a
été un sujet de crisp sur lesquelles il
y a pas eu de développement sur les 20
dernières années et maintenant que on n
pas avancé sur le nucléaire et que du
coup ça fait que on peut pas rapidement
en faire et bien on a quand même besoin
d'électricité décarboné et ce qui est
plus rapide à faire en terme
d'électricité décarboné c'est l'éolien
et le solaire mais manque de chance pour
des raisons physiques ça occupe beaucoup
plus de place parce que l'énergie
nucléaire est une énergie extrêmement
dense et concentrée
avec 15 sites nucléaire en France on
fait la totalité enfin pas la totalité
on fait les tr/4 de l'électricité
française il faut si je si j'ai si je ne
tient pas compte des bâtiments
administratifs annexes il faut 1000 fois
plus de surface pour faire la même
quantité d'électricité avec du solaire
qu'avec du nucléaire donc il faut bien
la trouver quelque part cette surface et
donc comme par ailleurs c'est compliqué
et donc plus cher d'installer inst aller
les panneaux sur les toits des
habitations parce que à chaque fois on
installe des petites surfaces une par
une donc ça multiplie les opérations et
cetera c'est beaucoup moins cher et ça
serait vrai même si l'opérateur était
public c'est pas une affaire de de
profit et de capitalisme c'est juste une
affaire de coût économique c'est
beaucoup moins cher de faire ça au sol
en supprimant un champ ou une forêt
voilà c'est considérablement moins cher
donc ce qui est en train de se passer en
ce moment c'est que on est en train
d'essayer de rattraper la production
électrique décarboné qu'on n pas fait
sur le nucléaire sur des moyens qui vont
plus vite à mettre en œuvre et qui par
ailleurs étaient plus consensuel dans
l'opinion quand vous demandiez aux
Français il y a encore quelques années
qu'est-ce que vous pensez des énergies
renouvelables il vous disait à 80 % on
trouvait ça très bien je juge pas s'ils
ont tort ou raison je vous dis juste en
terme d'acceptabilité sociale c'est
comme ça que ça se présenter et puis par
ailleurs à la campagne il y a personne
donc vous emmerdez pas grand monde quand
vous faites des champs de panneaux
solaires vous emmerdez trois
propriétaires de Git dans le coin euh
mais c'est pas énor et pareil pour un
champ éolien ça fait pas beaucoup de
monde donc euh la la la ligne de pente
euh nous a emmené de ce côté-là
maintenant il va falloir qu'on se mette
d'accord avec nous-mêmes euh
c'est-à-dire on peut pas dire on veut
pas d'énergie fossile pas de nucléaire
et pas de champ de PV et en même temps
du pouvoir d'achat il va falloir qu'on
se MRE d'accord avec nous-mêmes donc ce
qu'il va falloir qu'on fasse c'est il va
falloir qu'on soit un tout petit peu
adulte et qu'on voit quels sont les
inconvénients qu'on accepte et ceux
qu'on naccepte pas est-ce qu'on préfère
avoir quelques centrales nucléaires et
pas beaucoup oup de champ de panneau
est-ce qu'on préfère avoir moins de
centrale nucléaire et beaucoup plus de
champs de panneau est-ce qu'on préfère
ne pas avoir d'énergie du tout et faire
du vélo sans assistance électrique enfin
voilà je caricature un peu mais il va
falloir qu'on se mette d'accord avec
nous-mêmees et aujourd'hui je trouve que
ce débat là il reste encore gentiment
enfantin
euh on on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout
du courage en se disant qu'est-ce qu'on
veut
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
bon j'ai pas une bonne nouvelle c'est
que le temps avance et dans un quart
d'heure il
faudra sortir libérer la salle donc ce
qu'on va faire on va prendre les trois
dernières interventions donc c'est
maintenant à à droite et donc dans les
réponses des intervenants il y aura
également la conclusion de cette soirée
ça sera très bref je pense en estant
être un peu taquin pour réseau salariat
parce que j'ai l'impression que le le
système
d'écrit offre pour jargonnet peu d'écart
type par rapport à la moyenne
c'est-à-dire en fait peu de bio je sais
pas mais sociodiversité c'est c'est mon
intuition et on vient de parler un peu
du nucléaire je voulais en fait donner
du temps de parole sur la notion de
déchet parce qu'on a peut-être une marge
de progression importante tente toute
chose étant égale par ailleurs et
précisément dans le nucléaire évidemment
le thème du déchet et
névralgique bonsoir merci beaucoup pour
votre intervention qui fut fort apprécié
ma question concerne la place accorder à
l'intelligence artificielle dans la
société à venir et et simplement dans un
contexte où elle ne fait que progresser
dans le monde du travail
merci
c'est vous qui avez la
parole il faut que ce soit un
homme interveneheure on a pris questions
prendre de
questions question très rap dans un
contexte de contraction justement de la
ressource à l'énergie qu impact sur la
population mondiale et comment gérer les
conséquences et vous madame
bonsoir et
merci question pour Monsieur Friot
est-ce que vous pourriez expliciter
comment est-ce que vous voyez la
transition entre le travail et la
retraite bien que la retraite ne veille
pas dire fin du travail peut-être en
prenant un exemple de profession et en
imaginant comment vous voyez ça et
deuxème question pour tous les
deux qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on vient
de finir nos études ou ou pas enfin
qu'on est jeune que on est à peu près
conscient de des enjeux que vous avez
discuté ce soir euh qu'on a l'impression
d'être à peu près engagé soit
associativement parlant soit dans notre
profession et qu'on ne peut que
constater que actuellement les les temps
caractéristiques de transformation du
système sont bien trop grands pour
éviter le premier récueil dont vous avez
parlé monsieur jankovici à savoir euh
ben le fait qu'on soit forcé par des des
chocs naturels à à
décroître
merci
je crain de pas avoir compris la
question excusez-moi mais est-ce que
c'est j'ai demandé à Dani qui a pas
compris non plus donc est-ce que vous
pouvez la reposer s vous moi j'ai très
bien compris mais je comprend tout
mais a des gens plus stupides que ici
alors donc c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
quand on est jeune c'est ça c'est
ça tout à fait voilà et ben on y
va allez Jean-Marc c'est à toi puisque
c'est Bernard qui a commencé tout à
l'heure alors je vais essayer de traiter
les trois questions sur lesquelles j'ai
un truc à répondre euh la question des
déchets nucléaires est effectivement un
sujet qui fait partie des préoccupations
qui remontent haut euh quand on demande
aux gens quels sont les inconvénients
qu'il voit l'énergie nucléaire c'est un
truc qui va assez haut alors euh
paradoxalement moi c'est pas un truc qui
m'empêche de dormir mais voilà c'est pas
moi qui fait l'opinion française
euh dans alors il y a il y a deux
problèmes dans le nucléaire en fait qui
se rejoignent il y a le problème du
déchet et il y a le problème de la
ressource parce que en fait aujourd'hui
si on veut que le nucléaire soit un
déterminant significative à l'échelle
mondiale euh où vous avez alors je suis
désolé deemployer cette unité il y a
2200 GW de centrale à charbon dans le
monde euh pour vous donner une idée he
le parc nucléaire français c'est 63
c'est 60 GW de puissance hein et il y a
2200 GW de puissance de centrale à
charbon dans le monde enfin un gros
paquet si on veut que le nucléaire joue
un rôle significatif à l'échelle de ce
parc de centrale à charbon on peut pas
rester sur la technologie Act du
nucléaire qui n'utilise qu'une toute
petite partie de l'uranium c'est-à-dire
l'isotope 235 donc on est obligé de
passer à la génération d'après qui
utilise tout l'uranium euh et à ce
moment cette génération elle a aussi un
avantage qui est de limiter la quantité
de déchets produites elle en fait
beaucoup moins voilà donc mais encore
une fois les déchets pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur chaque Français
aujourd'hui via la quantité
d'électricité nucléaire qui est générée
par français dans ce pays il génère des
déchets en kikinant là ceux qui sont à
haute activité à longue durée de
vie l'ordre de grandeur par personne
c'est une pièce de monnaie une pièce de
monnaie par personne et par an donc
c'est des cochonneries mais c'est des
petits volumes donc c'est pas quelque
chose qui est c'est beaucoup plus
emmerdant de bazarder 50000 tonnes de
phytosanitaire dans la nature tous les
ans ou de bazarder 10 tonnes de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère par français et par an
c'est des choses qui se gèrent moins
bien
alors je suis beaucoup plus pour
l'intelligence naturelle pour
l'intelligence artificielle
personnellement euh je pense
que je je préfère euh voilà on devrait
peut-être faire un label ou une
appellation d'origine contrôlée
intelligence garantie intelligence
naturelle
euh et alors une réponse un peu plus
sérieuse vous aurez compris que dans un
monde dans lequel les flux physiques
vont baisser ça revient à dire que si on
veut garder la même quantité de gens au
travail la productivité du travail va
baisser donc ce qui vise à augmenter la
productivité du travail va plutôt dans
le mauvais
sens globalement hein encore une fois
sans prendre parti sur qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire en terme de revenus de
distribution des revenus de pouvoir
d'achat et cetera juste sur cette partie
làà en gros c'est absolument vous avez
en France entre 2000 entre 1974 et 2007
on a doublé la production industrielle
en divisant les emplois industriels par
de ça c'est le résultat de
l'augmentation de la productivité du
travail dans l'industrie c'est-à-dire du
remplacement des gens par des machines
c'est très exactement ça qui s'est passé
euh donc si on veut que les gens
continuent à avoir un emploi après c'est
un débat qu'on a pas eu ce soir mais
est-ce que c'est important ou pas dans
la société d'avoir un emploi
personnellement je pense que oui parce
que je pense qu'il une composante de la
nature humaine qui est d'être utile aux
autres et c'est un truc qui est un peu
biologique ça date de l'époque où enfin
ça date du c'est lié au fait que comme
on est des animaux sociaux être utile
aux autres quelque part c'est notre
c'est c'est notre sécurité que le groupe
va prendre soin de nous-même d'accord
quand on est utile aux autres c'est
voilà on a cette garantie et donc
l'emploi c'est c'est une matérialisation
moderne de ce sohait d'être utile aux
autres c'est comme ça que je
l'interprète je me trompe peut-être mais
c'est comme ça que je l'interprète donc
c'est important de garder des emplois
dans une société en transition et donc
si on veut garder beaucoup d'emplois
dans une société en transition ben
malheureusement n déplaise aux
économistes au pouvoir d'achat et même à
moi-même peut-être euh la augmenter la
productivité du travail est pas
nécessairement une bonne idée voilà donc
je par ailleurs je pense qu'il y a un
effet de démission alors bon que
certaines applications précises de
l'intelligence artificielle mieux
identifier les tumeurs sur les radios ça
soit pas idiot ok mais après en faire
l'alpha et l'oméga partout et tout le
temps je pense qu'il faut être il faut
bien se poser la question de la finalité
quoi et
enfin qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est
jeune alors d'abord on reste pas seul
quand on a des questions comme ça parce
que non mais vraiment parce que sinon on
déprime et on devient
neurasténique et donc une des premières
choses à faire c'est de rejoindre des
entités où y a des G qui posent des
questions euh identiques euh et la seule
chose qui nous sort de la neurastthénie
c'est de passer à l'action enfin en tout
cas c'est ce que je crois euh et donc ça
veut dire que il faut essayer de
rejoindre une entité ou le travail quel
qu'il soit on sauve pas le monde soit
tout seul al il y a un truc qu'il faut
pas faire quand on est jeune c'est de se
prendre pour Atlas personne ne porte le
poids du monde sur ses épaules et il
faut surtout pas chercher à le faire
parce que sinon on est sûr de déprimer
euh et donc il faut simplement essayer
de trouver un endroit où une partie de
l'angoisse va se libérer au travers de
l'action alors ça peut être associatif
hein extion rébellion c'est comme ça que
il se libère de l'angoisse ça peut être
euh ça peut être professionnel euh ça
peut être d'aller travailler dans une
entité où on se sent utile et encore une
fois on va pas sauver le monde à soit
tout seul mais se sentir utile ça suffit
et tout ça démarre en général avec
trouver des réseaux dans lesquels on a
des gens qui qui qui vous ressemblent
euh c'est-à-dire des gens qui partagent
les mêmes préoccupations alors un tout
petit peu de plaidoyer PRODOMO puisque
mon voisin de gauche l'a fait tout à
l'heure au sein des shifters il y a des
gens qui discutent de ce genre de sujet
ça fait partie de leur
préoccupation
et et il y a des gens qui partagent ce
genre de de préoccupation et qui peuvent
aussi du reste donner des conseils sur
comment ils l'ont vécu eux s'ils sont un
peu plus âgés et comment est-ce qu'ils
ont réussi à concilier cette
préoccupation avec ce qu'ils font dans
leur vie de tous les jours voilà mais
vraiment faut pas rester seul
VO
donc Bernard il nous reste moins de 10
minutes euh sur l'intelligence
artificielle je je je pense à tout ce
travail de reporting pour lequel euh
tant aujourd'hui sont invités à à écrire
ce qu'ils font à passer du temps à
écrire ce qu'ils font
euh pour qu'ensuite
leur
leur travail soit fait par
l'intelligence
artificielle
euh faut être un peu bête je veis dire
pour faire du reporting hein euh pour
accepter le reporting c'est pour ça dire
que ceux qui refusent le reporting sont
l'objet d'une chasse par les directions
totales je pense à tel ingénieur qui
refusait de faire le reporting dans la
gestion des barrages hydroélect
je pense à à toute une série de
soignants qui refusent de faire du
reporting et qui font de la
clinique sans écrire ce qu'ils font sans
passer le quart de leur temps à écrire
ce qu'ils font et à préparer leur
remplacement par de l'intelligence
artificiel le remplacement de la
clinique par du protocole le
remplacement de de
l'intersubjectivité par l'abstraction
l'intelligence artificielle pour venir
ici j'étais dans le train ce matin un
train d'ailleurs c'est dans la vallée de
la Roya on ne peut y moner qu'après que
trois flics et vérifier qu'il y a pas de
migrants enfin il y a une chasse aux
migrants absolument
ignoble dans cette vallée nous dépensons
60000 € par jour à payer des des
gendarmes des en prenant le train cette
fois-ci c'était avanthier je fais 9 K K
pour aller de che là où j'habite à la
gare j'ai rencontré où j'ai été arrêté
par pas moins de 16 gendarmes et flic
d'accord et
militaire nous sommes dans le pays de
cioti et
donc et et d'une politique antimigrant
qui est une honte
nationale
et donc je discutais dans le train après
que ces pandores a vérifié qu'il y avait
pas de de de migrant au fè évidemment he
toujours hein tout ça est au fè
euh le avec une responsable de la
gestion de l'eau dans le parc du
Marcantour et qui et qui fait de la
présence physique au milieu des lac dans
des barques pour mesurer la température
enfin et cetera qui euh avec des
constats d'ailleurs extrêmement alarmant
et qui et qui dit
que actuellement ce qui se met en place
progressivement que ce soit les
les à partir de de de
de de de vaisseaux spatiaux que euh
toute la surveillance de la température
des lacs soit soit soit faite sans
intervention des humains et donc par de
l'intelligence
artificielle mais qu'est-ce que ça va
donner cela chaque fois qu'elle est
physiquement sur ce la qu'elle voit des
tas d'autres
chose la la la
la l'occasion de prendre la température
de l'eauf c'est c'est l'occasion pardon
la prise de température de l'occasion de
faire de tous autres constats aussi
euh si nous perdons le rapport sensible
et physique avec la nature au bénéfice
de l'intelligence artificielle ça va
donner le pire c'est absolument évident
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc s'agissant
maintenant
de qu'est-ce que font les
jeunes d'une part encore une fois les
jeunes sont accablés de l'insertion
en 1977 Raymond bar invente le le plan
de sauvegarde de l'emploi des jeunes de
45 à 75 être jeune n'a aucune incidence
sur le marché du travail aucune c'est
même plutôt bénéfique on observe une
hausse du salaire d'embauche si bien que
dans les familles ouvrières par exemple
où le salaire est relativement plat la
carrière assez plate les enfants gagnent
pratiquement autant que leurs parents ce
qui d'un point de vue sociologique est
extrêmement intéressant ça légitime cole
ça ça évite de devoir aimer perdument
ses parents sien veut pas crever de faim
c'est même les grands-parents
aujourd'hui il faut aller jusqu'aux
grands-parentsattend de la Sébille et
donc la la la la ça ça ça a entraîné un
retard dans la mise en couple ça
entraîner une et cetera et cetera bien
les effets sociologiques sont absolument
désastreux de cette baisse du salaire
d'embauche et ça concernait au départ
les
jeunes peu certifié
et puis si vous prenez je sais pas quoi
voilà ce scandale des emplois jeunes
hein dans la gauche
plurielle là c'est bac+ 2 d'accord et on
peut sstra souscrire un entemploi jeune
la veille de ces 30 ans c'estàdire qu'on
est jeune jusqu'à 35 ans avec le SMIC
pendant 5
ans pour des gens qu' bac + 2 voilà
voilà toutes ces mesures jeunes alors
ajoutons aujourd'hui je sais pas quoi
des volontariat de service civique enfin
des des monstruosités où on avoque le
civisme pour pas payer les gens à
travailler la la la la
la il faut d'abord sortir la jeunesse de
la calamité de
l'insertion il n'y a aucune raison que
l'âge soit une catégorie de
discrimination sur le marché du travail
or il l'est aujourd'hui massivement
après 50 ans et avant 35
ans
maintenant pour une autre
dimension c'est pour cela que salaire à
18 ans d'accord enrichissement de la
citoyenneté droit au salaire à 18 ans
comme droit politique c'est évidemment
la réponse
à cette
ignominie de l'obligation de
s'insérer dans les
années je pas dans les années 80 un CV
d'étudiant c'était trois lignes
aujourd'hui c'est 10 pages où il montre
tout ce qu'il fait pour pour pour pour
pour pour s'insérer enfin c'est c'est
c'est un
descent et donc sur l'autre dimension
qui
est ce refus de plus en plus
important hein de de participer à la
folle fuite en avant dans la production
de marchandis en vue du profit ou dans
les grands projets absurdes ce ce refus
qui marque de plus en plus des
jeunes et qui qui se traduit par de
l'exit globalement il n'entre pas dans
les entreprises les services
public et il ils font à la marge des
activités conformes à leur
déontologie pour moi ce sont des
communistes hein toute personne qui
refuse de travailler contre sa
déontologie est communiste toute
personne qui travaille selon sa
déontologie est communiste il y a une
urgence de ce point de vue-là de
communisme évidemment sauf que tant
qu'il reste à la
marge il dérange
personne voire même beaucoup de
recherches et développement aujourd'hui
est fait gratos pour le capital par des
dissidents et dès qu'ils ont trouvé le
business model hop aussitôt vous avez un
Trô capitaliste au Xavier Nil par
exemple d'accord qui achète regardez je
sais pas quoi là la ruche qui dit oui
par exemple et
donc le logiciel propriétaire se nourrit
du logiciel libre enfin et cetera et
cetera donc il est absolument décisif
que ces
dissidents dont je salue la
dissidence sortent de la marginalité et
c'est là que les sécurité sociale
sectorielle parce que précisément elle
solvabilise des acheteurs auprès de
professionnels conventionnés et ce sont
ces dissidents que nous allons
conventionner bien
sûr leur fournir un marché les sortir de
la marge là les projets de sécurité
sociale sectorielle que nous que nous
proposons un réseau salariat et pas qu'à
réseau salariat nous sommes maintenant
dans de très nombreuses groupement
association syndicat qui travaillent sur
ces questionsl sont en particulier en
utilisant l'outil du conventionnement et
en ne conventionnant pas évidemment les
entreprises capitalistes sont les les un
outil extrêmement important pour sortir
cette jeunesse dissidente de la marge et
lui permettre enfin d'être heureuse au
travail Bernard il faut qu'on s
merci ben
écoutez je propose qu'on remercie nos
inter nos intervenants encore une fois
a même des
qui bien merci à vous merci à toute
l'équipe du Grand Théâtre de Provence et
puis je vous propose qu'on sort assez
vite de la salle pour se retrouver dans
le hall à tout de
suite